WE'RE GONNA CALL TO ORDER THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES
AND ENERGY -- WE ARE WAITING
FOR FOR COMPLEMENT OF MEMBERS
SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT UNTIL SUCH TIME
WILL OPERATE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
OF MISTER BY STIR YOU HAVE NO
OBJECTIONS OKAY -- WE HAVE JUST
A COUPLE OF HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
AGAIN MISTER -- EDUARDO GARCIA
IS ABSENT TODAY MISTER NAZARIAN
WILL BE FILLING IN FOR HIM
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF ITEMS ON
CONSENT ITEM TO A.
B. NINE TWENTY THREE
WEEKS I DON'T FOR A BI TEN
SEVENTEEN ORDER HOWEVER
AND WE HAVE -- MS BURKE WHO
WILL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA THAT'S ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTY SIX ITEM ONE AND -- ALSO
BE PRESENTING ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETY THREE LIVING
NO NO NO NO JUST JUST LET
EVERYONE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE AND AND ACTUALLY
MOST AFTER MS FREEMAN AFTER
YOU PRESENT YOUR TWO BILLS
THAT WILL BE ALL COMMITTEE SO
WE'LL WE'LL TURN TO YOU AT THAT
POINT BUT FOR NOW WILL WELCOME
YOU -- FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
ON ITEM FIVE A. B.
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
TO BE FOLLOWED BY
ITEM EIGHT AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY NINE I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS POLICY AND I'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
IS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN EXPERIENCING
MORE FREQUENT AND DEADLY
WILDFIRES DURING TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE THE
LARGEST BUYERS EVER RECORDED IN
HISTORY.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT A
MAJORITY OF THE SOURCES OF
IGNITION FOR WILDFIRES ARE DUE
TO HUMAN ACTIVITY INCLUDING
ENERGIZED ELECTRIC POWER LINES.
DE ENERGIZING POWER LINES HAS
BEEN PROPOSED AS A MITIGATION
MEASURE TO REDUCE AND IGNITION
SOURCES DURING PERIODS OF
ELEVATED FIRE RISK.
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT THAT REALLY
LEADS TO SIGNIFICANTLY READ LIZ
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE SERVICE
RELIABILITY FOR COMMUNITIES IN
THESE HIGH FIRE THREAT AREAS.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMERS
OF HAS A HAVE ALREADY HAD THEIR
ELECTRICITY SHUT OFF DURING DE
ENERGIZING EVENTS.
AND THAT OF COURSE IS DISTURBING
TO RESIDENTS AND CAN BE LIFE
THREATENING IF IT THERE ARE A
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
ON THE OTHER HAND ENERGY STORAGE
AND DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
LOCATED IN AFFECTED COMMUNITIES
CAN ENABLE ESSENTIAL LOADS TO
REMAIN SERVICE IN THE FACE OF
MORE FREQUENT THE ENERGY.
ENTERED DE ENERGY STATION EVENTS
AND PROVIDE RESILIENCY FOR THE
COMMUNITY.
AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR REQUIRES
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO USE UP 210% OF THE
SELF GENERATION AND INCENTIVE
PROGRAM FROM FROM TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TO BE ALLOCATED TOWARDS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FACILITIES IN HIGHER FIRE THREAT
DISTRICTS.
THE INCENTIVE FUNDS FROM THIS
BILL COULD SUPPORT MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE LARGE FACILITIES
SUCH AS WATER SUPPLIERS WASTE
WATER AGENCIES HOSPITALS AND
CAMPUSES.
AND MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED SMALL
FACILITIES SUCH AS SCHOOLS AND
FIRE STATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS A
WITNESS IS JOHN KENNEDY FROM
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN KENNEDY WITH
RC RC THE RURAL COUNTIES -- OUR
MEMBER COUNTIES HAVE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S FORESTED
LANDS AND WE'VE BEEN SUBJECT TO
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE RECENT
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
SO WITH THAT WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF EVERY EFFORT TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF WILDFIRE --
SEVERAL OUR COUNTY IS WORD DE
ENERGIZED IN AN OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EVENT -- ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND RESIDENTS HAVE THEIR
POWER SHUT OFF SOME OF THEM WERE
THAT POWER FOR ABOUT THREE DAYS
UNTIL P. JEANNIE COULD INSPECT
THE LINES AND RESTORE POWER --
THAT YOU KNOW WE UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR THE INTERPRETATION TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF WILDFIRES BUT
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THERE
ARE RISKS THAT COME WITH IT.
SO A LOT OF THE RESIDENTS WERE
WITHOUT WATER FOR DRINKING --
COULDN'T FLUSH TOILETS -- THERE
WERE SOME COMPROMISED WATER AND
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANTS --
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE ON THE VERGE
OF VIOLATING SOME -- BURN OFF
LAWS SO WE DO THIS BILL AS BEING
A A COMPLIMENT TO PROMOTE LOCAL
RESILIENCY TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES -- DEAL WITH THE
INTERPRETATION OF EVENTS -- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FOCUS OF
THE BILL ON CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE POLICE
STATIONS FIRE DEPARTMENTS
SCHOOLS WATER AND WASTEWATER
FACILITIES ESPECIALLY HOSPITALS
HAVE TO REMAIN OPEN -- THERE'S
NOT AN OPTION FOR THEM TO BE
POWERED DOWN DURING THESE TYPES
OF EVENTS SO WE THINK THIS WILL
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES BE A LITTLE
MORE RESILIENT -- HELP OUR
RESIDENTS AS THEY WORK THROUGH
THESE TIMES -- LOOK FOR TO
SEEING HOW THE AS CHIP PROGRAM
CAN ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS IN THE
THIRD NEW AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT COULD BE USED
IN THE PROGRAM OR OTHER PROGRAMS.
THAT WILL HELP US DEAL WITH AND
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF THE
ENERGY STATION SO WITH THAT WE
SUPPORT THE BILL AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL OF SO COME FORWARD.
AND WE ARE TAKING.
THOSE WHO JUST INTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
YOUR AFFILIATION.
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL MY
NAME IS MICHAEL DAY I'M WITH
TRAIN WHICH IS A DIVISION OF
INGERSOLL RAND -- AND I'M HERE
SPEAKING TODAY ON ONE OF OUR A
COMMUNITY THAT WERE WORKING WITH
THEM LAKE COUNTY WHICH IS A
MEMBER OF RC RC -- WORKING WITH
HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE AND AND
SEVERAL OTHER RURAL COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE IN A HIGH FIRE DANGER
AREA THEY'VE HAD FOUR MAJOR WILD
FIRES IN THE LAST SIX YEARS.
THEY'VE SUFFERED FROM DE ENERGY
IS ATION AND AS WE'VE BEEN
HELPING THEM LOOK AT THINGS
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT FOR THE LEADERSHIP THAT
SHOWN BY THIS BILL.
BUT WE WANTED TO BRING UP SOME
THINGS THAT WERE SAYING IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION THAT MIGHT WANT
TO BE CONSIDERED.
THE SELF GENERATION INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT'S THAT'S BEING
LOOKED UTILIZED AS A GREAT
VEHICLE FOR THIS BUT THERE ARE
SOME PARTS THAT ARE IN CONGRESS
WITH THE WITH THE INTENT HERE.
FIRST OFF THE SELF GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS CAPPED.
AT ONE MAKE A WHAT.
THE INCENTIVES GET CUT IN HALF
AND THEN ABOVE TO MAKE WHAT'S
THEIR OF THEIR ELIMINATED AND
THIS COULD BE FOR LARGER
FACILITY SO COULD BE WORKING
AGAINST IT.
ALSO THIS IS TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THINGS THAT ARE A LONGER
DURATION STORAGE AND THE S. CHIP
INCENTIVE IS CUT IN HALF AT TWO
HOURS AND THEN IT'S CUT IN HALF
AGAIN OF FOUR HOURS.
SO THE WAY THAT THE S. CHIP IS
CURRENTLY INCENTIVES ARE
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED.
IS NOT EXACTLY AN ALIGNMENT AND
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING WHERE
DIRECTION THE P. YOU SEE WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL.
THE LAST PART IS IS THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE
ALLOWED AS POSSIBLE UNDER THE S.
CHIP PROGRAM.
IN ITS ENABLING REG REGULATIONS
BUT IN REALITY THE THE THINGS
THAT ARE ALLOWED. TO MOVE
FORWARD OR THOSE THAT ARE
EMBODIED IN THE S. CHIP HANDBOOK
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS HANDBOOK.
IF WE DON'T HAVE SOMETHING IN
THERE THAT ALLOWS THE PROJECTS
THAT ARE DONE HERE -- TO TO
POTENTIALLY COME UP WITH ANSWERS
THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
RECOGNIZED IN THE HANDBOOK
THERE'S NO WAY FOR THEM TO BE
EVALUATED.
AND SINCE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
INNOVATION THAT'S IT AGAIN A LOT
OF SUPPORT HERE FROM OUR
PARTNERS IN HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE
SOME A LOT OF OTHER RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE HOPING THAT COMMENTS
ON ON REAL REAL LIFE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND PROBLEMS CAN BE
ADDRESSED IN THE LEGISLATION TO
HELP MAKE IT THE SUCCESS THAT WE
ALL NEED IT TO BE.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
BECAUSE YOU ONLY HAD ONE WITNESS
WILL LET THAT.
COMMENT YOUR SECOND WITH US AND
THIS IS JUST NAME.
FILIATION AND YOUR SUPPORT YEP
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DAN CHAU
WITH US LOWER CONCEPTUALLY
SUPPORT OF STILL REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS.
ARE ENCOURAGED BY THEM -- BUT
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THEY'RE NOT SO RESTRICTIVE --
AND AND THAT THE PC -- CAN
DETERMINE EXACTLY WHAT TYPES OF
RELIABILITY PROJECTS -- CAN BE --
ELIGIBLE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE -- WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IS ARE
THERE ANY.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
IS OUR MOTION.
SECOND OKAY -- IT.
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE YEAH I'M
GONNA HEAD OF A YEAH WE'RE GOOD.
NO WE CANNOT A CORNER WE YES NO
IT JUST WE JUST IN OUR HEADS
WERE COUNTING INCIDENT WERE
THERE.
AND I SO I WANT TO GET AHEAD OF
OURSELVES WE DO HAVE -- WHAT
APPEARS TO BE A QUORUM SO IT'S A
ROLL CALL HERSELF?
HOLDEN.
HERE HOLDEN HERE PATTERSON
PATTERSON HERE BURKE.
WORK HERE CARILLO.
CHEN CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA HERE -- I'M
SORRY.
YES VERY YES GIVE ME MAYES
MURATSUCHI.
WORK [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
YEAH HERE [inaudible]
RAY AS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
NG.
OKAY THE MOTION WOULD BE -- WE
WERE SEVEN OSHA DO PASS A
NATURAL RESOURCES AS HAS OUR
SUPPORT AN ENDORSEMENT AND THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE TAKEN AND
NATURAL RESOURCES.
YES CRESCENT THEIR MOTION TO
THAT EFFECT.
SECOND OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED.
I SEE NO OUR COMMENTS BUT
SEVERAL CALL ON THE MOTION.
UNLESS YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE I'M
JUST SO I REALLY APPRECIATE --
THE VOICES OF SUPPORT -- MOVING
STORAGE AND INTO OUR VULNERABLE
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES IS A GOAL
THAT I THINK WE ALL HAVE AND I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH EVERYBODY I
APPRECIATE THE SUGGESTIONS WERE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
MAKE THIS -- WORKABLE FOR ALL OF
OUR WORLD COMMUNITIES AND AND
EVERYBODY ELSE THANK YOU
FANTASTIC THANK YOU FOR THE BILL.
ROLL CALL ON THE MOTION.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO NATURAL
SCIENCE NATURAL RESOURCES WITH
THE NAME IS TAKEN IN NATURAL
RESOURCES.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN HI PATTERSON
PATTERSON I BURKE [inaudible]
I CARILLO.
CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I WAS VERY YOUNG.
MAYES -- WHERE TWO G. MAYOR CITY
AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES?
SANTIAGO.
I TING.
WED ZERO AS EIGHT VOTES SO.
THE BILL CLEARS BUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR APPS MENTORS
OUT AT ON YOUR NEXT BILL IS --
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY SEVENTEEN
NINETY NINE YES I THINK THAT'S
IT IS ALSO -- HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WITH AMENDMENTS.
TO NATURAL RESOURCES AMENDMENTS
BE TAKEN A NATURAL RESOURCES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE AND I'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE.
FIVE RECENT PRICE.
THANK YOU -- THIS IS ABOUT
LOOKING INTO WHY NATURAL GAS
MARKETS HAVE BEEN SO VOLATILE
WE'VE BEEN APPROACH FIRE
UTILITIES AND PROBABLY MANY OF
YOU AS WELL TO FIND OUT WHAT'S
BEHIND THESE.
PRICE SPIKES AND SO WE WOULD
LIKE -- TO REALLY UNDERSTAND --
WHAT IS CAUSING THEM ON AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY NINE REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE DATA
REGARDING NATURAL GAS MARKETS TO
DETERMINE THE CAUSES OF NATURAL
GAS PRICE VOLATILITY EXPERIENCED
BY AND USE CUSTOMERS?
THE CDC WOULD ESTABLISH THE
JOINT AGENCY NATURAL GAS MARKET
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TO GATHER
ANALYZE MAKE REFERRALS TO THE
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO EVALUATE
WHAT DATE IS NEEDED TO
UNDERSTAND THE UNDERLYING CAUSES
A PRICE VOLATILITY AND THE STEPS
THAT COULD BE TAKEN TO LIMIT --
WELL A LOT OF THE STATE IS
SUBMITTED TO THE STATE IS DONE
SO IN A PIECE BILL MANNER AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT OUR UTILITIES --
WE HAVE A THREE IN MY DISTRICT --
SAY THAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THESE BIKES ARE HAPPENING
AND WHEN -- SO THIS WILL REQUIRE
THE COLLECTION OF INDIVIDUAL
NATURAL GAS TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION COMPANY DATA IN A
MORE HOLISTIC AND COMPREHENSIVE
MANNER.
THE BILL ALSO DIRECTS ALL LOAD
SERVING AND OF THESE I USE MUNY
SINCE CCA'S TO SUBMIT WHOLESALE
MARKET RISK MANAGEMENT PLANS
THESE PLANS WOULD INCLUDE HOW
THEY WOULD REDUCE THE RISK FROM
PRICE VOLATILITY IN THE WHOLE SO
ELECTRIC AND NATURAL GAS MARKETS.
WHILE REDUCING OVERALL
GREENHOUSE GASES AND INCREASING
THE USE OF CLEAN ENERGY -- WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS A WITNESS
IS TIM O'CONNOR WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I BOTH
THIS IS REALLY A TRANSPARENCY
BILL I'M AT ITS CORE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WICKS GOOD AFTERNOON MR HOLDEN --
TIM O'CONNOR WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FUND.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL REMAKING OUR
ELECTRICITY SYSTEM FROM ONE
WHICH WAS.
BASED ON COAL AND OIL TO ONE
WHICH DAY IS BASED ON GAS AND
RENEWABLES.
AND WE HAVE AT THE SAME TIME
HAVE HAD GAS UTILITIES WHICH
HAVE.
INVESTED HEAVILY IN A GAS
DISTRIBUTION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
NOW MOST OF OUR HOUSES AND
BUSINESSES ARE CONNECTED AND
TIED INTO THAT SYSTEM.
SO AS A RESULT CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS THE NATION'S SECOND LARGEST
USER OF NATURAL GAS OVER 90% OF
WHICH IS IMPORTED -- HAS MANY
PARTS OF OUR ECONOMY WHICH ARE
DIRECTLY TIED TO GAS PRICES TO
NATURAL GAS PRICES IS IN WITHIN
THIS CONTEXT WE FIND OURSELVES
TODAY. FOR ABOUT THE LAST NINE
YEARS THE ENERGY SECTOR AS
WITNESS PROLONGED VERY LOW
PRICES FOR NATURAL GAS.
AND THIS IS LARGELY DUE TO
ADVANCEMENTS IN UNCONVENTIONAL
GAS PRODUCTION TECHNOLOGY AND A
LARGE -- NATURAL GAS DELIVERY
SYSTEM WHICH IS MADE AVAILABLE
FOR FOLKS SO LAST YEAR WHEN
NATURAL GAS PRICES BEGAN TO
SPIKE IN EXPERIENCE SUDDEN SHARP
INCREASES.
MANY WERE LEFT UNPREPARED
RESULTING IN ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS OF EXTRA EXPENDITURES
FOR ELECTRICITY ALONE.
AT A RECENT -- ENERGY COMMISSION
MEETING ON THE SUBJECT OF PRICE
VOLATILITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS IDENTIFIED THAT THE EIGHT
OTHER THE AGENCY COULD NOT
IDENTIFY THE TRUE BECAUSE OF THE
PRICE FLUCTUATIONS THAT WAS
FOLLOWED UP BY TESTIMONY BY SI
PC PRESIDENT.
MICHAEL PICKER BEFORE US SENATE
OVERSIGHT.
HEARING -- ON MARCH TWELFTH THAT
THE CAUSE OF THOSE GAS PRICE
SPIKES COULD NOT BE IDENTIFIED --
WITH ABSOLUTE CLARITY WAS OF THE
LEASE -- CANYON OUT IT WAS IT
PROLONGED OUTAGES OF
TRANSMISSION PIPELINES INTO THE
SERVICE TERRITORY NOBODY COULD
SAY FOR CERTAIN.
EDF RECENTLY PERFORMED AN
ANALYSIS OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH
DATA IS AVAILABLE FOR USE BY
AGENCIES TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THE EFFECT OF
CHANGING STATE POLICIES ON THE
NATURAL GAS SYSTEM IN ITS
VULNERABILITY. TO IS TO PRICE
FLUCTUATIONS AS ANALYSIS HERE
WITH ME TODAY OUR ANALYSIS FOUND
THAT WELL MOST OF THE
INFORMATION EXISTS IT'S NOT
REGULARLY AVAILABLE AND ENERGY
AGENCIES CANNOT AND DO NOT
EVALUATED IN A COORDINATED AND
HOLISTIC MANNER.
THUS NO AGENCY HAS A COMPLETE
PICTURE OF THE VULNERABILITY OF
THE SYSTEM TO PRICE SWINGS LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR AND HOW
INVESTMENT DECISIONS GOING
FORWARD CAN MITIGATE IT.
AS THIS ISSUE MOVES FORWARD JUST
HAVING THE DAD OF COURSE WON'T
BE ENOUGH INFORMED DECISIONS
MUST RESULT THAT'S WHY WE THINK
THAT THE BILL'S PROVISION TO
REQUIRE LECTURE PROVIDERS TO
EMBED INTO THEIR LONG TERM
ENERGY PLANS.
STRATEGIES TO LIMIT THEIR
EXPOSURE PRICE VOLATILITY WHILE
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT.
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPECT FOR LIVE
BY THE THANK YOU -- WILL NOW
TAKE THE OTHERS ARE HERE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR THE BILL NAME AND
MEMBERS JOHN WHITE WITH A CLEAN
POWER CAMPAIGN WE THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL VERY TIMELY
AND FOR ALL THE REASONS STATE
THANK YOU.
MR TERM MEMBERS JENNA PRICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THEY WOULD WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE -- WOULD TURN BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
IS THERE A MOTION.
MOVES.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED -- SIMILAR FRIEDMAN D.
LIKE TO CLOSE I HAVE --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ROLL CALL ON
THE MOTION AND THIS IS A MOTION
TO PASS NATURAL RESOURCES WITH
THE AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
NATURAL RESOURCES.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO BURKE.
HI CARILLO.
CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HI CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI THIS AREA
[inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
CITY AYE QUIRK FIGHT HI REYES
SANTIAGO.
TEAM.
OKAY THAT BILL IS ON CALL AND
WILL YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU -- IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE TWO ITEMS
THAT WE HAVE FOR CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS WOULD BE SECOND.
OKAY.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
A ROLL CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO. THREE A I CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
WHEN I?
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
MAY.
MAYES I'M CITY YOUR CITY AYE
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEAM.
HEY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED AND WE WILL.
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON I WILL TURN NOW.
TO OUR FIRST ITEM FILE ITEM ONE
SENATE BILL FIFTY SIX AS I
MENTIONED AT THE ONSET.
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUARDO
GARCIA IS -- OUT -- TODAY -- BUT
HAS -- CONSENTED -- TO SIMILAR
BURKE TO PRESENT HIS BILL --
TODAY SO WE APPRECIATE THAT.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
COMMENTS IN HERE FROM HERE SEC.
THEY'RE GONNA BE GRIPPING AYE
FROM CAN I LET ME JUST -- LET ME
JUST LET YOU KNOW TOO THAT --
THE RECOMMENDATION IS A DO PASS --
TO NATURAL RESOURCES AND THESE
AMENDMENTS.
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS AND THEY
WOULD BE TAKEN AND NATURAL
RESOURCES YES SO I I SPEAK TO
THEM AND THE STATEMENT.
THE STATEMENT THAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED TO ME HERE ALL RIGHT --
OKAY SO CAN I ADDRESS THEM AT
THAT TIME.
YES YOU CAN GREAT -- SO GOOD AT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TODAY 2% AB
FIFTY SIX ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL ANALYSIS AND
AND BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE
SITUATION.
THAT THE PRIMARY AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO DISCUSS
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS -- WE
ARE WE WILL ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS HOWEVER I'M.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WELL ACTUALLY HIM IN ITS STAFF
AND I HAVE AGREED THAT WILL TAKE
THEM AT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THAT WITH THE HOPE THAT THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD -- WE WILL TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WILL MOVE
THE BILLS THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE ENERGY IN ADVANCE
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES
DRINKING THE INCLUSION OF PO USE.
AND LIMITING THE POTENTIAL SCOPE
OF PROCUREMENT.
BUT WE WOULD APPRECIATE A
COMMITMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE
THAT THIS LANGUAGE CAN BE
CONTINUE TO BE DISCUSSED AND
REVISE ONCE THE AUTHOR -- IS
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE INTHOSE
DISCUSSIONS.
I DON'T KNOW IS THAT IT OKAY YES
SIR AND THAT'S A YES.
THAT'S A YES WITH THE HOPE THAT
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO TALK TO HIM
I THINK -- THE BILL WILL CREATE
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN ELECTRICITY
AUTHORITY TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT NO ONE DISAGREES WITH THE
NATURE OF ENERGY PROCUREMENT IN
CALIFORNIA HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED.
CURRENTLY IF THERE IS AN ISSUE
WITH OUR GREAT FOR ANY REASON
THE STATE IS LEFT WITH LITTLE
RESOURCE RECOURSE OUR OPTIONS TO
ALLOW US TO ACT QUICKLY.
THIS NEW AUTHORITY WILL NOT
INTERFERE AT ALL WITH THE
PROCUREMENT AS IT CURRENTLY
HAPPENS BY THOSE SERVING ENEMIES
AND IS NARROWLY DEFINED TO
ADDRESS SPECIFIC SITUATIONS.
AS IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE.
AB FIFTY SIX DESIGNS THIS NEW
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE LIKE A
UTILITY THAT ONLY ACTS WHEN THE
WHEN DIRECTED TO BY THE STATE
AND IS SUBJECT TO ST STRICT
STATE OVERSIGHT.
IN THE EVENT THAT THE AUTHORITY
DOES PURCHASE POWER ANY
ASSOCIATED BENEFITS AND COSTS
LEFT OVER AFTER THAT POWERS SOLD
WILL BE PASSED ON TO REPAIRS.
BUT IS THE GOAL THAT THE
BENEFITS IN THOSE SITUATIONS
WOULD FAR OUTWEIGH ANY COSTS.
THIS IS THE RIGHT MOVE FOR
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS NOT FRIEDMAN FROM THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I MATT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WE ARE
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL -- THE
BILL.
COMES AT A VERY CRITICAL TIME --
AND WOOD.
DEVELOP A NEW BACKSTOP
PROCUREMENT MECHANISM. FOR A
LIKE TRICITY IN RELIABILITY
PRODUCTS UNDER SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES TO MEET THE
STATE'S RELIABILITY CLEAN ENERGY
CLIMATE RESOURCE PLANNING GOALS.
I'M WE ARE AS A STATE AT YET
ANOTHER CROSSROADS -- WE HAVE A
RISE IN COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION INCREASES IN DIRECT
ACCESS.
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES FACING
SERIOUSCREDIT CHALLENGES ONE OF
WHOM IS IN BANKRUPTCY -- AND BIG
QUESTIONS CIRCLING ABOUT WHAT
THE ROLE OF THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ARE GOING TO BE IN THE
FUTURE.
IN THE FACE OF THAT THE STATE
HAS TO MAINTAIN ITS COMMITMENT
TO COORDINATED RESOURCES AND
RELIABILITY PLANNING.
THESE FUNCTIONS HAVE EVEN
GREATER VALUE NOW THAN EVER
BEFORE.
THE FAILURE TO MAINTAIN STATE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE ACHIEVEMENT
OF THESE GOALS.
COULD SET THE STAGE FOR THE NEXT
ENERGY CRISIS OUR GOALS TO AVOID
THAT TO GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT.
LANDING THAT IS NOT BEING
REALIZED THROUGH ACTUAL
PROCUREMENTS THAT ARE BEING SEEN
IN THE MARKET BY RETAIL
PROVIDERS -- CAN BE DONE FOR A
BACKSTOP MECHANISM AN EXISTING
STATE LAW HAS THOSE BACKSTOP
MECHANISMS TODAY TO THE EXTENT
THAT RELIABILITY NEEDS ARE NOT
BEING MET THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY
UNDER EXISTING LAW TO GO OUT.
AND PROCURE BRAND NEW RESOURCES
IN CHARGE ALL CUSTOMERS FOR IT.
IF THE I USED DON'T DO IT.
THE CALIFORNIA I SO HAS THE
ABILITY TO STEP IN AND EXECUTE
CONTRACTS FOR RELIABILITY
RESOURCES AND TO CHARGE
EVERYBODY.
AND ALL OF THOSE COMMITMENTS ARE
SUBJECT TO REVIEW BY THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION.
IF WE DO NOTHING THOSE BACKSTOPS
WILL REMAIN IN PLACE.
BUT NOW IS THE TIME TO DESIGN A
NEW BACKSTOP MECHANISM. TO THE
ALTERNATIVES THAT WE HAVE ARE TO
INCREASE THE ROLE OF THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
AND THE CALIFORNIA I SO. TO GO
DEEPER ON THE MANAGEMENT OF
PROCUREMENT BY THE LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES LIKE CCA'S AND DIRECT
ACCESS PROVIDERS. FOR DEVELOP AN
INDEPENDENT MECHANISM THAT CAN
BE AVAILABLE TO STATE
POLICYMAKERS TO USE AS NEEDED.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS BILL WILL
NOT DO.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT TRANSFER ALL
OF THE PROCUREMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES TO CENTRAL
BUYER.
ON THE ENTITY WOULD SERVE AS A
BACKSTOP BUYER FOR RESOURCES NOT
PROCURED BY OTHER LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES BUT DEEMED NECESSARY TO
MEET GRADE RELIABILITY AND THE
SATISFIED DEFICITS IDENTIFIED.
IN THE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING PROCESS.
IT WOULD NOT CREATE A NEW AGENCY
THAT IS VESTED WITH POLICY
MAKING AUTHORITY -- OR DECISION
MAKING AUTHORITY.
THIS ENTITY WOULD BE A TOOL THAT
SIMPLY COULD BE USED TO ACHIEVE
STATE POLICY OBJECTIVES NO
POLICY WOULD BE MADE IT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO HAVE ALL OF ITS
PROCUREMENT AUTHORIZED IN
ADVANCE AND APPROVED AFTER THE
FACT.
BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THAT'S EXACTLY THE
WAY UTILITIES WORK NOW ADVANCED
DIRECTION FROM THE REGULATORS
AFTER THE FACT REVIEW AND
APPROVAL TO MAKE SURE ANY
COMMITMENTS ARE REASONABLE AND
TO APPROVE THE COLLECTION OF
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
COMMITMENTS.
I'M THIS APPROACH LEARN FROM THE
MISTAKES THAT WE MADE DURING THE
ENERGY CRISIS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND WHEN THE STATE WAS IN
CRISIS.
WE DEPUTIZED THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES TO GO OUT AND
SURVEY THE BACKSTOP ROLE IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN EMERGENCY.
WELL THEY BOUGHT A LOT OF POWER
BUT THERE WAS NO REVIEW AND
APPROVAL OF WHAT THEY DID.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO MAKE THAT TWICE.
THIS BILL COME IS A OFFERED A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT APPROACH
WHERE THE BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT
WOULD BE OVERSEEN BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
PROCUREMENT IS NOT CONSISTENT
WITH THE NEEDS OF THE STATE.
IT WOULD NOT BE APPROVED.
THE OTHER THING THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT DO IS IT DOES NOT HARM
RETAIL COMPETITION. FOR THE
EMERGENCE OF COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION.
THE BILL CLEARLY STATES THAT
CCA'S AND DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDERS REMAIN RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROCURING TO MEET 1100% OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS NEEDS.
IT'S ACTUALLY DESIGNED TO
RESPECT THE AUTONOMY OF LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES AND TO
FACILITATE INCREASED RETAIL
COMPETITION AND A HIGHER
PENETRATION OF COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION.
ON THE PROCUREMENT THAT'S DONE
ON A BACKSTOPS BASIS WOULD
REDUCE COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS
FOR ALL OF THESE ENTITIES.
SO EVERYONE WOULD GET CREDIT FOR
THE PROCUREMENT THAT'S DONE.
BUT THE POWER WOULDN'T BE
ALLOCATED TO THOSE CUSTOMERS
SPECIFICALLY LEAVING THOSE
PORTFOLIOS OPENED TO BE FILLED
BY THE LOCAL -- BUYERS TO MEET
OUR CUSTOMERS NEEDS.
THE BILL ALSO DOES NOT ESTABLISH
ANY NEW PROCUREMENT MANDATES
DOES NOT AUTHORIZE PROCUREMENT
BEYOND WHAT IS AUTHORIZED IN
EXISTING LAW.
IT LEADS ALL EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND REQUIREMENTS COMPLETELY
UNCHANGED.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT THINGS TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE BILL ITSELF.
IDENTIFIES PROCUREMENT. TO MEET
RESOURCE ADEQUACY NEEDS THAT ARE
ON MATT AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HAS ALREADY
IDENTIFIED AS THE TOPIC TO BE
DEALT WITH BY A CENTRAL BUYER IN
A RECENT DECISION.
IT ALSO LOOKS AT INTEGRATED
RESOURCE PLANNING IMMIGRANT
RESOURCES PLANNING DEFICITS THE
P. YOU SEE IN A PROPOSED
DECISION THAT IS DUE TO BE VOTED
OUT NEXT WEEK -- WOULD ESTABLISH
A PROCUREMENT TRACK IN WHICH IT
WILL BE LOOKING TO ESTABLISH
WHETHER ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENT
NEEDS TO BE DONE BY CENTRAL
BUYER AND UNDER EXISTING LAW
THAT CENTRAL BUYER.
IS THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY.
WE ALSO HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
UNDER THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD PROGRAM.
STARTING IN. 202165% OF ALL
COMPLIANCE MUST BE SOURCE FROM
LONG TERM CONTRACTS.
WELL THE RBS PROGRAM HAS A
PROVISION ALREADY.
THAT ALLOWS THE PC TO AUTHORIZE
A PROCUREMENT ENTITY.
ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS TO DO
PROCUREMENT ON BEHALF OF SMALL
OF SERVING ENTITIES.
THAT ARE HAVING TROUBLE MEETING
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS THIS.
ONE THAT PROVISION IS NEVER BEEN
OPERATIONALIZED OR IMPLEMENTED.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE A TOOL
FOR ALLOWING THAT PROVISION TO
BE TURNED INTO AN ACTUAL VIABLE
OPTION FOR LOW SERVING ENTITIES
THAT NEED ASSISTANCE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
COMPLEX TOPIC.
AND THIS IS A BIG PICTURE
CONCEPT.
WE UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS CHANGE THE SCOPE OF
THE PROPOSAL -- BUT WE THINK
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THIS YEAR. TO HAVE
A PROPOSAL LIKE THIS ON THE
TABLE FOR DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE THERE IS WIDE CONSENSUS
THAT THERE IS NEED FOR SOME KIND
OF A NEW BACKSTOPS TOOL IN THE
STATE.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE.
ONE WE'RE GONNA END UP HAVING TO
CREATE ONE IN A HURRY UNDER
DURESS AND OUR HOPE IS TO BE
AHEAD OF THE CURVE IN THIS
RESPECT.
THANK YOU.
THANKYOU AND BEFORE WE TAKE THE
THE NEXT WITNESS AND I
UNDERSTAND I APPRECIATE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERKS --
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT.
WE BELIEVE THE AUTHOR IS
PREPARED TO ACCEPT AS THE
AMENDMENTS.
BUT SINCE YOU ARE THE SPONSOR I
WANT TO ASK YOU ARE MORE YOU SAY
YOU'RE.
COMFORTABLE WITH OF THE AND
PREPARED TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL.
WE ARE MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD
SAY THAT WE'VE HAD NO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE STATE
AGENCY IDENTIFIED IN THE
AMENDMENTS AS THE AS THE HOME
FOR THIS NEW FUNCTION.
AND SO WE HAVE DONE NO DUE
DILIGENCE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE ARE ANY SHOWSTOPPER ISSUES
WHETHER THE ENTITY IS INTERESTED
IN TAKING ON THIS FUNCTION.
SO -- WITH THOSE COPY YACHTS AND
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT A
LOT OF ADDITIONAL WORK NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO FIGURE OUT IF THERE
ARE OTHER STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT
ARE PROBLEMATIC ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS.
THE ANSWER IS YES.
RIGHT.
I APPRECIATE THAT YEAH -- THANK
YOU SHOULD I THINK THAT THE THE
RELUCTANCE ON AT ON OUR PART IS
JUST WE HAVEN'T WE'RE WILLING TO
TAKE THE EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
WERE JUST HOPING TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MATERNITY OF
ENERGY AND EVENTS TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THEY ARE COMFORTABLE TAKING
THIS ON AND WHAT THAT PROCESS
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND HOW IT WOULD
WORK I THINK THAT THAT'S A REAL.
THE ONLY RELUCTANT YOU'RE
HEARING HERE IT'S NOT A
RELUCTANCE TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS RIGHT I KNOW AND I
THINK WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO GET
OUT WAS NO MATTER WHAT APPROACH
I THINK YOU MADE IT CLEAR IN
YOUR PRESENTATION THAT THIS IS A
NEW APPROACH THAT WERE.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME MODELS
OF WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN THE PAST
THERE WERE SOME FLAWS ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO FIND A WAY
TO KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING --
NOT NECESSARILY LOOKING AT A
COMPLETE START UP.
WHERE THERE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ATTACHED TO THAT BUT
TRY TO FIND A MODEL THAT -- HAD
THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS THE KINDS
OF ISSUES THAT.
AND WE AND BROUGHT OUT IN A
PRESS AND WE UNDERSTAND OKAY
THANK YOU YEAH SO THAT WAS FOR
CLARIFICATION -- SO WILL BEFORE
WE TAKE QUESTIONS THEN WE'LL
COME BACK AND YOU CAN FINISH
YOUR PRESENTATION AND THEN.
SO DOCTOR EGGMAN WE WILL GET TO
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR HOLDEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JEFF CIPHERS I'M VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICE ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT NINETEEN LOCAL PUBLIC
CCA'S IN CALIFORNIA SERVING TEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
AND WE'RE WE'RE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I
WANT TO QUALIFY THAT LATER IN MY
REMARKS BECAUSE ITS IMPORTS ARE
YOUR AND OPPOSITION.
TAKING OF THOSE IN FAVOR.
UNDERSTOOD HOW WE WILL NOT
COMPLETELY UNDERSTOOD BUT SO IF
THERE.
SO IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE PROPOSAL.
REMEMBER IT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TO EMAIL AND ASK
ABOUT THE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE.
SINCE I WOULD BE THE SECOND --
WITNESS JUST MY TAKE ONE SECOND
TO SAY WE CONCUR WITH THE TIME
THE NEED FOR THE TIMING OF THIS
BILL -- AND MOVING FORWARD
BEFORE THERE IS A CRISIS A
BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND IF THERE'S A LORD AS HE
MINISTER SEMPRA ENERGY THERE'S
IT ANYMORE -- OPPOSITION WE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS WE PROVIDED SOME
AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND OUTLINED THOSE AMENDMENTS IN
OUR LETTER AND HOPE THAT WE CAN.
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO SEE IF WE CAN
FIGURE SOMETHING OUT.
APPRECIATE THE AND IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN BETWEEN.
OKAY BUT I SEE SOME OTHER
MOVEMENTS SO IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE WHO IS PREPARED TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOUR
TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME OR
FOREVER HOLD YOUR PEACE.
OKAY WE HAVE AN IN BETWEEN.
BILLS FOR THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION WE DON'T HAVE
A POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE
DID SUBMIT A COMMENT LETTER.
OBVIOUSLY ANY CHANGES IN
PROCUREMENT OUR KID KEEN
INTEREST TO US ON BEHALF OF
AGRICULTURAL RATE PAYERS IN THE
STATE AND WE UNIFORMLY.
PAY IN CALIFORNIA TWICE AS MUCH
ELECTRICITY COSTS AS NEIGHBORING
STATES SO WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THESE TYPES OF BILLS AS THEY
MOVE FORWARD IN WILL BE
INTERESTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VALERIE TERRELL OF
LAJOS WITH PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY WE ALSO
SUBMITTED A COMMENT LETTER.
DON'T HAVE A POSITION BUT WANTED
TO ECHO QUICKLY SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SAID.
THIS IS COMPLEX -- THERE'S BEEN
SOME DEMONSTRATED NEED P.
JEANNIE SUPPORT WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE PC IN THE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY SPACE.
WE ARE OPEN -- TO CONTINUING THE
ACTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR -- AND YOUR COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DANIEL MILLS ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA -- WE
ALSO HAVE NO POSITION ON THIS
BILL BUT WE DID SUBMIT A LETTER --
CONSIDERATIONS THAT INCLUDED
SOME PRINCIPLES FOR PROCUREMENT
GOING FORWARD.
JUST RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS A
VERY UNCERTAIN TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA'S UTILITIES AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPERS WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS --
SEEKING TO FIT THIS INTO AN
EXISTING -- STRUCTURE THAT MAY
WORK AND WILLING TO EXPLORE THAT
FURTHER -- AND WE DO WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROCEED WITH THIS
CONVERSATION VERY CAREFULLY AND
DON'T TAKE ANY STEPS THAT ARE
GONNA.
FURTHER COMPLICATE OF
PROCUREMENT GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
SHANNON IT IN WITH A LARGE SCALE
SOLAR CESSATION WE ARE TWEETERS
ON THIS -- ONE WORDS STILL
DIGESTING THE IMPORT OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND WHAT KIND OF
IMPACT IF THAT'S GOING TO HELP
ON THE LANGUAGE WHAT WE WILL SAY
IS THAT -- CALIFORNIA'S
OBVIOUSLY GOING UNDER OF MASSIVE
TRANSITION RIGHT NOW AND WE WANT
TO PROTECT AGAINST THE TENDENCY
TO REACH TOO FAR OVER IN A
COMMAND AND CONTROL STRUCTURES.
IN THE NEVER TO TO ACHIEVE SOME
STABILITY SO WE DO THINK THAT
THERE'S A ROLE FOR CENTRAL
BACKSTOP ENTITY IF IT'S A LITTLE
MORE SURGICAL -- WE LISTED SOME
OF THOSE SOME OF THOSE ELEMENTS
ARE LETTER AND OUTLOOK FOR THE
NEXT UP SOME TO WANT TO SEE THE
BILL KEEP MOVING THANKS THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TWENTY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
AND THE SAME TWEENER SECTION --
OUR LETTER DID HIGHLIGHT
PRINCIPLES THAT WE THINK.
CAN HELP INFORM THE DISCUSSION
THANK OF THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE SPACE
AND WE AGREE THAT.
DOING SOMETHING BEFORE THERE'S A
CRISIS IS DEFINITELY NEEDED --
IN THE SPACE THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS TRANSMIT ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION WE HAD
SUBMITTED OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
LETTER I BELIEVE BASED ON THE
AMENDMENTS WHERE YOU'RE NOW IN
THE TWEENER SECTION UNTIL WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO REVIEW THE
AMOUNT ABOUT SADDENED UP OR TAKE
A LOOK AT HIM.
THANK YOU.
WHICH CHAIRING MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENTING ANOTHER CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE ACCEPTED TODAY WE
WITHDRAW OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOUR STAFF IN THE AUTHOR
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS CHAIR
MEMBERS ANTHONY SAMPSON ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY AGAIN APPRECIATE --
THE CHAIRS PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND AUTHORS AND STAFFS
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THEM AND
WITH THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THEM IN THEIR FORMING THE
NEXT COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- NO OTHER.
INBETWEENERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'LL ACCEPT YOUR TESTIMONY ON
BEHALF OF THE OPPONENTS POLICIES
FOR JUMPING THE GUN EARLIER.
SO -- JOB CIPHERS WITH KELSEY CA --
WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION WE DO
THINK THIS BILL IS SEEKING TO
SOLVE A REAL PROBLEM -- BUT AS
WRITTEN WE BELIEVE IT WOULD MAKE
MATTERS WORSE -- WE DO NEED TO
PROTECT GRADE RELIABILITY -- BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO DO IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T HURT A RENEWABLE ENERGY
GOALS.
SO I'D LIKE TO REMEMBER THAT
CCA'S WERE CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE MARKET
STABILITY DURING PEAK GINNY'S
FIRST BANKRUPTCY.
AND BACK THEN GAMING BY SOME
ENERGY CORPORATIONS CONTRIBUTED
THE BLACKOUTS AND HIGH RATES.
WE NOW HAVE OPERATING CCA'S AND
THEIR STRONG INTEREST IN
STOCKTON AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIAN HAD EXPAND CCA RATE
PAYER ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
TO INCLUDE EVERYONE.
THE THE CURRENT BILL WOULD HAVE
A CENTRAL BUYER HANDLE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS -- BUT LET'S
CHECK THAT ON RENEWABLE ENERGY
THE CCA'S ARE CONTRACTING TO
BUILD RESOURCES AT A RECORD HIGH
RATE -- WE'VE ALREADY FINANCE
TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS WE EXPECT
TO FINANCE A THOUSAND MORE
MEGAWATTS THIS YEAR ALONE AND WE
PLAN TO BUILD TEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THE I. O. U.'S
HAVE NO NEED TO BUILD NEW
RESOURCES BECAUSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE VOTING TO FORM
MORE CCA'S.
ON RENEWABLE AT RESOURCE
ADEQUACY OR ARE A THAT MATTER IS
DIFFERENT IN A BILL THAT FOCUSES
SOLELY ON OUR A WOULD ACTUALLY
BE WELCOME TO US.
IT'S IMPORTANT -- TO ENSURE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
ISN'T ACCIDENTALLY STOPPED
BECAUSE CC IS ARE DEVELOPING
THOSE TEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS.
FOR BOTH ENERGY AND RELIABILITY
THOSE TWO FACETS OF A PROJECT
ALWAYS GO TOGETHER -- AND ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
RENEWABLE INTEGRATION.
SO ANY HARM TO OR TAKING AWAY
POWERS FOR RESEARCH ADEQUACY
COULD ARMOR ABILITY TO BUILD NEW
ENERGY SOURCES.
SO WE ARE REACHING OUT TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO WORK -- TO CREATE A DEFAULT
PROCUREMENT ENTITY FOR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY ALONE.
IT WOULD ENSURE THAT THE NEEDS
ARE COORDINATED BETWEEN ENERGY
COMMISSION THE I SO IN THE PC.
AND CONTINUE TO ALLOW ELECTRIC
PROVIDERS TO BUY RESOURCES AS
THEY DO NOW THE BILL ISN'T AS
CLEAR ON THAT POINT AS WE WOULD
LIKE.
THEN AFTER THE LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES HAVE PROCURED THE
DEFAULT BUYER WITHIN STEP IN AND
BY ANY REMAINING NEEDED
RESOURCES AND ASSIGN THE COSTS
IN THAT BACKSTOP MANNER TO
ANYONE WHO DIDN'T PARK HERE.
AND IT WOULD THOSE COSTS WOULD
FLOW TO THE GENERATION SIDE OF
THE BILL THAT'S ANOTHER
IMPORTANT PIECE WE'D LIKE TO SEE.
GOOD BACKSTOPS ARGUMENT LIKE
THIS WILL PROTECT OUR GRID
WITHOUT HURTING RATE PAYERS
ENERGY JOBS OF THE CLIMATE AND
WE'RE READY TO HELP DRAFT OUT
BILL.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
JUST LENDING YOUR YOUR NAME
FILIATION AND APPOSITION.
ADAM SMITH WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY SIX
AS IT'S WRITTEN WE THINK THAT
THE BILL I THAT DOES IDENTIFY A
CRITICAL PROBLEM WHICH IS THE
LACK OF CENTRALIZED PLANNING AND
PROCUREMENT OVERSIGHT OVER SOME
LOADS SERVING ENTITIES.
WE THINK AB FIFTY SIX PROPOSES
THE WRONG SOLUTION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JASON I
OCCURRED -- WITH THAT'LL STEAM
GILBERT ROPES AND SMITH ON
BEHALF OF CLEAN POWER SF ALSO IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION OR
NO FURTHER COMMENTS -- WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO THE CHAIR INDICATED AND I
WOULD AGREE WITH HIM THAT WE
NEED A VEHICLE GOING FORWARD TO
DISCUSS THIS PROBLEM.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT.
I MEAN I HAVE PROBLEMS WITH IT
TOO BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
HAVE THE VEHICLE GOING TO HAVE
THE DISCUSSION GOING WHICH WAS
ALSO MENTIONED BY THE SPONSOR.
OF FOR THAT REASON I'LL NOW
MOVED TO BAIL.
IS OUR SECOND.
THAT WOULD BE INTERESTING.
YOUR I GUESS I GET IT I'M ON THE
COMMITTEE I CAN'T -- JUST THEN
THE COMMENT ON THE BALLOT.
FIRST OF ALL WE DO I'D LIKE TO
ASK THE SPONSOR QUESTION SO WE
DO HAVE A BACKSTOP NOW.
AND THAT IS THE I SO CAN SAY
THIS PLANT MáS RYAN --
SOMETIMES THEY HAVE A CONTRACT
IN ONE CASE AT LEAST THEY HAS
THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
TO MAKE CONTRACT -- SO ITS
RELIABILITY MUST RUN -- AND
FRANKLY I TRUST THE ISO MORE TO
MAKE THAT DECISION IN THE C. P.
U. C. WHICH IS WHAT'S IN HERE.
THE I SO HAS FAR BETTER MODELS
WE SEEN THE CPUC CHANGE THE I SO
REQUIREMENTS. FOR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY WHICH MAKES NO SENSE AT
ALL BECAUSE THEY KNOW A LOT LESS
THE AYE IT SO DOES.
SO MY FIRST COMMENT IS WE
SHOULDN'T BE RELYING ON THE C.
P. U. C. TO THE SIDE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY THAT OUGHT TO BE -- THE
I. S. SHOW -- SECOND -- THERE
NOW THERE IS A PROCEDURE.
AND I THINK WITH OUR I BELIEVE
THIS THE I SO PERHAPS THE CHAIR
CAN CORRECT ME IF I DON'T HAVE
THIS I BELIEVE THE I SO IS NOW
STARTING TO LOOK OUT.
AT ALL A LARGER HORIZON.
MARY CANCER THAT [inaudible]
ITSELF.
NOT BEING FOCUSED ON WELL
CERTAINLY.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON A LARGE
HORIZON WE DO KNOW.
THAT UNDER THE LAST RESOURCE
ADEQUACY.
LOOK BY THE R. C. P. YOU SEE
THAT -- THERE WASN'T RESOURCE
ADEQUACY -- AND THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO TELL THE CCA'S
TO DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY THAT'S
NOT.
WE HAVEN'T GIVEN THEM THAT
AUTHORITY -- AND I WOULD ASK THE
C. C. A.'S -- TWO I THINK THE
BEST THING TO DO HERE IS TO ASK
THE C. C. A.'S.
ARE FOR THEM TO WORK TOGETHER --
ON THIS ISSUE -- WHEN WE HAD?
YOU KNOW ONE UTILITY IN CHARGE
OF A LARGE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA WE
COULD JUST DEPEND UPON THE
UTILITY.
I THINK NOW THAT WE GOING HAVE --
CCA IS AND IN THE SAME TERRITORY
AS I USE -- AND JUST THE
COMPLEXITY OF THAT -- I WOULD
ASK THEM TO ADD TO WORK.
WITH THE I. AT I USE AND TRYING
TO COME UP WITH A PLAN TO COVER
PARTICULAR REGIONS -- AND THEN
FINALLY -- WE DO HAVE A PROCESS
AND I'M NOT SURE IT'S BROKEN BUT
I DO THINK THAT THE CCA'S HAVE
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
AND HERE THEY SORT OF CUT OUT I
WANT THEM TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
AND I KNOW THAT THEY WANT -- TO
TO GET THE PROPER BALANCE ON THE
GRAD.
SO -- THAT THAT'S MY COMMENT I'M
STILL SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I
THINK -- I HOPE THAT -- WELL WE
CAN KEEP THE COMMAS AND PERIODS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST A A SHORT
RESPONSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
CURRENTLY THE PC DOES HAVE
PRIMARY JURISDICTION OVER
RESOURCE ADEQUACY OVERSIGHT AND
COMPLIANCE BY LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA -- TO
MOVE THAT PROGRAM ENTIRELY AS TO
THE ISO WOULD BE A PRETTY
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE THIS BILL
DOESN'T DISTURB THE CURRENT.
SITUATION WITH RESPECT TO A
JURISDICTION AND AUTHORITY --
AND UNDER THE EXISTING PROGRAM
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
DEFICITS IDENTIFIED THE PC HAS
THE AUTHORITY AND HAS IN FACT
USE THAT AUTHORITY TO DIRECT THE
I USED TO GO OUT AND DO LONG
TERM CONTRACTS FOR BRAND NEW
RESOURCES SAID THAT'S KIND OF
THE DEFAULT.
THAT WE'RE THE WORLD WE'RE
LIVING IN TODAY YES BUT THEY
DON'T ALWAYS FOLLOW THE I SO
DIRECTION.
AND SO I DON'T TRUST WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THE I. SL KNOWS THEIR MUCH THE
MODELS THAT THEY HAVE THIS TO
PETE CPUC ARE INFERIOR AND YET
THEY WILL CHANGE WHAT THE ISO
RECOMMEND SO THAT'S A PROBLEM.
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT TAKEN
CARE OF BUT THE OTHER THING IS.
I MEAN WE REALLY HAVE.
TO I WAS NEVER IN FAVOR OF
HAVING CCA'S BUT NOW THAT
THEY'RE HERE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO PUT.
THEM TOGETHER WITH ALL THE LOAD
SERVING ENERGIESIN THE REGION
AND TO WORK THESE THINGS OUT
TOGETHER BEFORE WE HAVE
GOVERNMENT -- SAME THIS OR THAT
I THINK THE I SO IS REALLY THE
ONLY ONE WHO CAN TELL US.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S RESOURCE
ADEQUACY AND I THINK THEN WE
SHOULD RELY ON THE CCA'S TO WORK
WITH THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES.
AND TO GET A GOVERNMENT AGENCY
INVOLVED.
I'M NOT REALLY QUITE READY FOR
THAT BUT WE DO NEED TO DISCUSS
IT JUST TO CLARIFY THIS BILL
DOES NOT I'M SORRY.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT GONNA YEAH YEAH
OF THE PERSON.
ADDRESSED HER UP. ONE AT A LINE
OF MY CONCERNS WITH THE MIST
QUIRK -- WANT TO THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING HERE FROM AN FOR THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY ON THE
PLANET [inaudible]
WE ARE.
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
UNCERTAIN WHAT ITS ELECTRICITY
GRID IS GONNA LOOK LIKE GOING
FORWARD LOOK WHERE WE ARE.
WE ARE ESSENTIALLY I THINK
SLOWLY.
DISINTEGRATING THE GRADE THAT WE
HAVE HAD SERVE US WELL FOR A
LONG LONG TIME.
AND I RECOGNIZE.
THE NECESSITY TO AT LEAST HAVE
THIS KIND OF CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
I WOULD.
SUGGEST THAT THE P. YOU SEE DOES
NOT.
HAVE THE FAVOR I THINK OF THIS
COMMITTEE WITH RESPECT TO THAT
KIND OF DECISION ON ON AYE AYE --
APPRECIATE THE DOCTOR QUIRKS.
COMMENT ON THIS.
I THINK MY OVERARCHING CONCERN
IS THAT THIS.
I DON'T THINK IS READY FOR PRIME
TIME JUST YET.
I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE THERE'S
GOT TO BE A SERIOUS -- PLANNING --
OVER THE NEXT PERIOD OF TIME
HERE -- AS I SAID I MEAN WITH
THIS THAT TWENTY YEARS IN THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY OUT WE WE
HAVE A HUGE ECONOMY. TO ENERGIZE
KEEP ENERGIZED AND TO HAVE IT
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE.
THE SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE
WE'VE SEEN RELIABILITY GO DOWN
AND IF AT AT AT AT AND OF AND
AFFORDABILITY GO DOWN.
AT AS A RESULT WE ARE WHERE WE
ARE.
I'M I'M PREPARED AND I THINK
THIS COMMITTEES PREPARED TO LOOK
AT WHAT THAT NEXT -- GRADE
[inaudible]
LOOKS LIKE.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO BE.
CAREFUL MORE CAREFUL.
A LITTLE BIT SLOWER.
AND HAVE SOME CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS -- AND I WOULD JUST
SAY WHAT TROUBLES ME THE MOST IS
THIS FEELS LIKE.
THAT WHAT WE ARE GOING TO END
WITH IS A GOVERNMENT ENTITY THAT
IS DICTATORIAL AND THAT CAN
COMMAND.
AND WHEN THAT COMMAND IS -- DONE
IT WILL BE THE RATE PAYERS THAT
WILL.
BE FORCED TO TO PAY FOR THAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
AS WELL SO FOR THOSE REASONS I
DO THINK THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
THIS -- CONVERSATION AND WE DO
NEED A A A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
GRID SOLUTION BUT I THINK THAT
TAKES.
DEEP THINKING ALL PARTIES AT THE
TABLE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SO
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS SPACE ON
WINNERS IN.
OPPOSITION AND NOT AND ON OTHER
SITES I THINK ARGUES FOR THAT
KIND OF CONVERSATION SO I'M
GONNA.
LAY OFF THE BILL -- I DO THINK
THAT THERE HAS TO BE MUCH MORE
WORK ON IT AND I'M GOING TO
RESERVE MY FINAL VOTE FOR THE
FLOOR.
THROUGH THE CHAIR THE CHAIR CAN
I YES -- I JUST LIKE TO DRESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON I
AGREE -- WE SHOULDN'T BE HERE WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE PREPARED
BUT THE REALITY IS WITH THE
SITUATION THAT WE FIND OURSELVES
IN WE DO HAVE -- I USE THAT ARE
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY WE DO HAVE --
RELIABILITY ISSUES ON THE BRINK
AND THE REALITY IS IS WE HAVE TO
WE ARE FOR WE HAVE.
PUT OURSELVES IN A SITUATION WE
ARE FORCED TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION NOW.
WE NEED A BACKSTOP WE DO NOT
HAVE AN OPTION AND I THINK.
AN OPPOSITE I SEE WHAT YOU HOW
YOU SEE THESE POINTERS AS
OPPOSITE YES IT IS A VERY VERY
COMPLEX ISSUE.
AND YES IT IS TAKING A LOT OF
TIME EVEN JUST TO GET HERE BUT
AS YOU SEE PEOPLE MOVING FROM
OPPOSITION IN THIS LONG LINE OF
TRAINERS THAT IS A SHOW OF THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE WITH THAT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THAT THE AUTHOR
IS WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
THAT WE ARE MOVING THE NEEDLE ON
WHERE THEY SHOULD GO IN
NARROWING IT SO THAT IT IS NOT
DICTATORIAL SO THAT IT IS
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS DESIGNED TO
BE WHICH IS A BACKSTOPS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A LARGE
ENOUGH PLACE WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY. FOR CARE AND NOT FOR
TO REDUCE THE RATES FOR FOLKS SO
I THINK THAT THE INTENTION AND
THE MOON.
DIRECTION IN WHICH THIS BILL IS
MOVING IN IS IS CORRECT AND AND
UNFORTUNATELY I WISH WE HAD TEN
YEARS TO DEAL WITH THIS.
BUT WE DON'T WE HAVE PLACED
OURSELVES ANY SITUATION WITH THE
I. YOU USE IN THE WAY THAT WE
DID TO ARE THOSE WHO DESIGNED
THE SYSTEM BEFORE US.
DID.
AND SO SOMETHING LIKE THIS I
THINK WHAT YOU CAN SEE IS
EVERYBODY IN THIS LINE EVEN THE
OPPOSITION HAS SAID ONE THING.
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THIS A
SOLUTION NEEDS TO BE FOUND AND
THAT THIS IS IN THE SCOPE OF THE
SOLUTION NOT PERFECT.
NEEDS WORK NEEDS TO BE WORKED
WITH WITH THE CCA'S BUT MOST
DEFINITELY PART OF THE SOLUTION
THAT NEEDS TO BE FOUND AT LEAST
A PORTION OF IT.
AND I THINK ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
PERSON THAT HAS STOOD UP FOR
SPOKEN TODAY HAS SAID SOME
VERSION OF THAT EXCEPT FOR I
THINK TWO HUNDRED TWO THE I SO
IS NOT IDENTIFIED THE SYSTEM
DEFICIENCY SO.
THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT THE CPC ALSO RECENTLY
ACCEPTED OUR RECOMMENDATION FOR
A THREE YEAR OBLIGATION PRETTY
RECENTLY IS ONLY A ONE YEAR
OBLIGATION FOR RESOURCE ADEQUACY.
AND SO I THINK WE'RE MOVING ON
THE RIGHT TRACK [inaudible]
DR.
WHAT I AND I I DO REALLY I DO
APPRECIATE THIS I REALLY DO?
I'M NOT SAYING WE HAVE TEN YEARS
OUT I THINK THE P. JEANNIE
BANKRUPTCY.
PROBABLY AS A TWO OR THREE YEAR.
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES I KNOW THAT
WE OFTENTIMES IN THE MIDST OF
CRISIS WE SAY WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT WE DO THE
RIGHT THING I DO THINK THERE ARE
INCOMPLETE PIECES IN HERE AND WE
HAVE EXPRESSED SOME OF THOSE.
INCOMPLETE PIECES AND THAT'S WHY
PRESENTLY I'M GONNA LAY OFF
APPRECIATE THE THE CONVERSATION
I REALLY DO.
YEAH WELL I THINK WE ALSO MY
BROKEN RECORDS I THINK WE ALL
SHARE A LOT OF THE CONCERNS I
ALSO THINK THAT I A SO IS THE
BETTER A BODY.
I GET TIRED OF US GIVING MORE TO
THE C. P. U. C. TO DO AND THEN
BRING THEM IN HERE BEATING THEM
UP NOT DOING.
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE ASKED THEM
TO DO AND WE JUST PILE ON SOME
MORE IS THAT THAT IS COUNTER
INTUITIVE DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE --
AND I REPRESENT AG DISTRICT AND
THERE WHEN WE USED TO HAVE A TON
OF PROCESSING WE DON'T HAVE
ANYMORE BECAUSE THE COST OF
ENERGY IS IS TO PRICES PEOPLE
OUT I MEAN WE MUST ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF COST.
AND RELIABILITY -- AND IT'S YOU
KNOW IT'S TOO BAD I THINK
AUTHORS NOT HERE AND AND SOME
MEMBER BURKE IS IN A FANTASTIC
JOB OF STEPPING UP AND STEPPING
IN -- BUT THE SPACE IT NEEDS I
MEAN THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WE
CAN DO QUICKLY I FIND MYSELF
ALIGNING MYSELF WITH MR PATERSON
SAYING BUT SOME WE NEED TO MOVE
BUT SOMETIMES MOVING TOO QUICKLY.
IS AS BAD AS NOT MOVING AT ALL --
SO I THINK WE NEED TO GET THIS
RIGHT AND GO TO NATURAL
RESOURCES NEXUS AT WHERE IT WILL
GO ALRIGHT.
SO I WILL BE ORDERING IT THERE.
SUMMER SEARCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT -- TO
HIGHLIGHT THE CONCERN THAT ICE
IS C. AND THE CAL CCA LETTER
THAT.
TO WHILE THIS IS BEING PRESENTED
AS FOR A BACKSTOP THAT THE LESS
THAN GRANT OF AUTHORITY IS BROAD
ENOUGH THAT THERE'S CONCERN AT
LEAST THAT THE AUTHORITY COULD
BE USED FOR ANY PURPOSE.
REGARDING PROCUREMENT AND SO YOU
KNOW I REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT
HAS A LARGE -- PARTS OF IT THAT --
ARE COMING UNDER THIS --
EXCITING TO NEW CLEAN POWER
ALLIANCE -- A PROJECT AND I I
THINK -- YOU KNOW RATHER THAN.
VOTING ON YOU KNOW A PROJECT IN
ITS WORKS I YOU KNOW.
I CANNOT SUPPORT WHAT IS BEFORE
US HERE TODAY AND SO I WILL NOT
BE PUTTING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
OKAY WE HAVE -- OKAY THIS CREEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO GIVE A THANK YOU TO MISS
BURKE FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL I
KNOW IT'S NOT EASY. TO TO
PRESENT ON A COLLEAGUES BILL BUT
I'M SURE MR GARCIA'S VERY
APPRECIATIVE TO YOUR WORK -- AND
TO ALL OF US HERE LET US JUST
REMEMBER THAT IF THE AUTHOR WERE
HERE HE'D BE ABLE TO ADDRESS ALL
THESE QUESTIONS HIMSELF.
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL THANK.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND AND AGAIN
THANK YOU.
I WAS BURKE THIS IS A YEAH.
BUT BUT YOU YOU UNDERSTAND THE
SUBJECT I DID THINK.
COMPLETELY HOLD WATER YOU'RE A
VERY COMFORTABLE PLACE -- AND
AND I THINK THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION -- THAT WERE
MAKING IS TO KEEP THE BILL
MOVING ALONG WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS A COMPLICATED A SUBJECT --
AND BUT WHAT IS A COMPLICATED IN
THIS -- IN THIS PARTICULAR LINE.
OF BUT I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE
TO BE MINDFUL AND WE DID GET A
SIGNAL FROM THE PC PRESIDENT AND
ARE.
A HEARING ABOUT A MONTH OR TWO
AGO WHERE HE INDICATED THAT.
MOVING TO SOME TYPE OF A
BACKSTOP OR CENTRAL PROCUREMENT
AUTHORITY WAS GOING TO HAVE TO
HAPPEN AT SOME POINT SO I THINK
THAT THE CONVERSATION IN THE
MARKET PLACES TO SUGGEST THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OURSELVES
HAVING TO GET TO THIS PLACE.
AND SO IT WAS THIS COMMITTEE'S
RESPONSIBILITY SORT OF GET THEIR
ARMS AROUND THIS ISSUE TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW. TO PROPOSED BACK
AT LEAST TO A PROCESSOR SYSTEM
THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE -- TO GET US INTO
THE AREA GET US INTO THE
CONVERSATION TO ALLOW US TO LOOK
AT SOME TYPE OF A STRUCTURE THAT
WOULD AT LEAST.
A COMPLIMENT -- THE END GOAL BUT
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT WE WEREN'T
MOVING TOO FAST WITH TWO NEW OF
A PROCESS TO NEW OF A STRUCTURE
THAT.
REQUIRED START UP IN OF A LOT OF
OTHER COMPONENTS THAT WE WERE
COMPARED PREPARED AT THIS POINT.
TO OPINE ON IN IN GREATER DETAIL --
BUT WE DO THINK THAT THIS --
PROPOSAL IS REASONABLE -- ALLOWS
FOR THE CONVERSATION AND I THINK
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS AS YOU
POINTED OUT WE WERE ABLE TO SORT
OF SHRINK THE UNIVERSE OF
OPPOSITION -- THERE ARE STILL
CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL ALONG.
TO A NATURAL RESOURCES FOR THE
CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE AT THAT
POINT -- WE ARE -- THIS IS A DO
PLACE ENJOYS A DO PASS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES AND THE
AMENDMENTS.
THAT ARE PROPOSING THIS
COMMITTEE WILL BE TAKEN IN
NATURAL RESOURCES.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
IF THERE ARE NO OTHER COMMENTS
AT THIS POINT -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
NOT JUST NOT WITH THE OFFER BUT
WITH MYSELF AS A TAKE ON A BILL
THAT IS NOT MINE BUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME THAT YOU AND YOUR
STAFF HAVE PUT INTO THIS AND
THANK YOU TO THE TO THE OTHER
MEMBERS FOR TAKING THIS.
SERIOUSLY I UNDERSTAND IT IS
COMPLICATED I UNDERSTAND IT IS
IMPORTANT -- BUT AS I KNOW
THAT'S AUTHOR HE WILL WORK VERY
VERY HARD WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
MOVING FORWARD.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
I THINK THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT I MEAN CERTAINLY.
FAMILY -- SITUATION HAS TAKEN
AWAY FROM US TODAY BUT HE WILL
BE BACK AT HIS AS WE KNOW A VERY
ENGAGED AND AND AND VERY
COLLABORATIVE AUTHOR SO -- WE
HAVE A MOTION -- DO PASSES --
MENTION TO WITH THE MINISTRY
TAKEN AND NATURAL RESOURCES.
CALDERON.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
LOADING.
BURKE I BURKE I DO.
RELY CHEN [inaudible]
AND VOTING [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
AND VOTING.
QUIRK ALRIGHT.
HI REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO TEAM.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTE SO WE
NEED ONE MORE SO IT'S ON CALL.
SENATOR AND WELCOME.
AND IN ITS WALKED IN SO WE'LL
COME BACK TO YOU AT A AT A LATER
TIME.
I SO IT IS ON CALL WE ARE ONE
VOTE SHY DO YOU WANT ME TO GO
FOR THE NEXT.
YES.
YOUR AT IT LET'S LET'S DO THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER LIVING.
NO ONE WAITING WHEN I WENT OVER.
THIS IS -- YOUR PRESENT A MISTER
LIVING AYE WHICHEVER ONE YOU
WANT I GOT A POLICY YEAH WELL I
KNOW WE WHEN WE DISPENSE OF MR
LEVINE YOURS COMES AFTER IN THE
FILE ORDER SO WILL -- TAKE A. B..
TWELVE NINETY THREE AND THIS
ENJOY TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THE AUTHORS AGREED TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS.
I I'M SURE.
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- THANKYOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS YOU ARE LONG FROM
DONE WITH ME -- I'LL BE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ADD
AGRICULTURE CUSTOMERS TO THE
RATE IMPACT ANALYSIS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE.
A CALIFORNIA WE THE NATION IN
CLEAN ENERGY REALIZATION AND
TACKLING THE CHALLENGES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AVERAGE WHOLESALE ELECTRICITY
PRICES IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE
SAME AS IN TEXAS AND I THE U. S.
AVERAGE HOWEVER THE STATE'S
ELECTRICITY RATES ARE AMONG THE
HIGHEST IN THE NATION.
AND ROUGHLY TWICE AS HIGH AS THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE THE MAIN REASON
FOR THIS JUST FOR THE DISPARITY
IN CALIFORNIA IN RATES IN
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY.
OF COVERS NUMEROUS ENERGY AND
ENERGY EFFICIENT PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN MANDATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN ADDITION TO STANDARD FIXED
COSTS LIKE TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTED TO BE SOME LINES IN
THE YEARS SINCE THE STATE'S
ELECTRICITY CRISIS.
INTEREST HAS GROWN IN THE
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACT OF
MANDATED PROGRAMS ON REPAIRS TO
THAT END IN RECENT YEARS THE P.
YOU SEE HAS ANNUALLY PUBLISHED
ACTIONS TO LIMIT UTILITY COSTS
AND RATE.
AB TWELVE NINETY THREE AS
ANOTHER INFORMATIONAL TOOL FOR
THE EFFORT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
REPAIR COSTS WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IT'S
CALIFORNIA MOVES TOWARDS MUCH
GREATER ELECTRIFICATION OF
VEHICLES AND HOMES.
ELECTRICITY RATES THAT ARE TOO
HIGH COULD IMPEDE THIS AMBITIOUS
A LOT OF LOCAL.
HAVING THE MORE PRECISE RATE
IMPACT INFORMATION THAT THIS
BILL WOULD HELP PROVIDE WILL
HELP POLICY MAKERS BETTER ASSESS
AND DETERMINE THE BEST POWER
PATH FORWARD OF CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUED TO INCREASE ITS
EXPANDABILITY EFFORTS.
WITH ME THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
SUPPORTERS.
THAT I'M PROBABLY GONNA NEED.
OKAY WELL IF THE START TO YOUR
RIDE AND WILL -- TAKE LESS MONEY
MISTER CHAIR CAN'T COUNT ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC
AND SO CAL GAS WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL -- AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN SECOND RATE
REFORM CHANGES SINCE AT LEAST
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE WERE ABLE
TO GET AB THREE TWENTY SEVEN
APPROVED WHICH HAS NOT YET BEEN
FULLY IMPLEMENTED.
RATES ARE CONCERNED OUR RATES IN
SAN DIEGO ARE AMONG THE HIGHEST
IN THE STATE.
LAST YEAR IN WORKING WITH SOME
REMEMBER BURKE AND OTHERS -- BUT
WE DID A REVIEW OF WHAT THE OF
MANDATED PROGRAM COSTS WERE
WITHIN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY.
AND WE ESTIMATED NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR OUT OF REVENUE OF JUST
OVER FOUR BILLION SO IT'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF OUR REVENUE
THAT COMES IN.
IF YOU PUT THAT IN CONTEXT ON
WHILE FOR MITIGATION WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON MITIGATION EFFORTS
FOR ELEVEN YEARS NOW AND WE'VE
SPENT JUST OVER ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS.
SO THE MANDATED PROGRAMS ARE
VERY SIGNIFICANT PART OF OUR OF
OUR RATES WERE ALSO WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE ON TEN
EIGHTY THREE WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HERE IN A COUPLE
WEEKS.
AND THAT SEEKS TO TAKEN EARLIER
LOOK AT IT BEFORE THE COMMITTEES
DECIDE MOVING FORWARD ON A BILL
TO IDENTIFY.
IN A HOLISTIC WAY MOST BILLS
THAT WE IN THE UTILITY INDUSTRY
WORK ON ARE A MATTER OF COST
IMPLICATIONS BETWEEN ONE GREAT
PAIR CLASS FIRST ANOTHER.
AND WE THINK THESE THIS FOCUS ON
WHAT THOSE IMPACTS ARE ON
REPAIRS IS IMPORTANT AND
THEREFORE WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF TURN IN
SUPPORT -- WE LIKE THE FACT THAT
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
INCLUDE THE COST OF THESE
MANDATED PROGRAMS ON A PER THERM
OR PER KILOWATT HOUR BASIS.
IN ITS ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND AS AN ATTACHMENT
TO EACH AGENDA TO A PC BUSINESS
MEETING.
I THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE THE IS THE PC TENDS TO
LOOK AT EACH PROPOSED SPENDING
ITEM ON ITS AGENDA IN COMPLETE
ISOLATION.
AS IF THERE WERE NO OTHER
CUMULATIVE INCREASES THAT THEY
HAD TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
IT BEGINS TO FEEL A LOT LIKE
FREE MONEY -- WITH NO HARD TRADE
OFFS THAT NEED TO BE MADE WE
THINK THAT THIS BILL IS A VERY
SMALL.
BUT MEANINGFUL STEP.
TOWARDS FORCING THE REGULATORS
TO GRAPPLE WITH THE CUMULATIVE
IMPACTS OF ALL OF THE CHOICES
THAT ARE BEING MADE BOTH BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THE CHOICES THAT THEY HAVE
BEFORE THEM AT A BUSINESS
MEETING -- WE DO HAVE A CRISIS
OF AFFORDABILITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE RECORD
NUMBERS OF SHOT OFTEN PEOPLE
BEHIND ON BILL PAYMENT -- AND WE
NEED TO GET THE REGULATORS TO
FOCUS THEIR ATTENTION ON THE
FACT THAT EVERY TIME THEY
APPROVE AN ADDITIONAL RATE
INCREASE THERE ARE REAL
CONSEQUENCES -- AND WHEN YOU ADD
THEM TO ALL OF THE MANDATED
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED BY THE LEGISLATURE --
THAT ADDS UP TO REAL MONEY THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI SO ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE -- TO I ADD ON TO THIS SO
SUPPORT YES AT BEST A LOSS SO ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE AMENDED --
OBVIOUSLY THE ADDITION OF THE I.
GRATES A BRINGS US INTO FULL
SUPPORT SO WE THINK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THAT AND LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL NEXT
COMMITTEE.
YES OVER THERE IN CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE WERE ALSO
SPUR OF AMENDED AND APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS AND RENOUNCE
PARTS THANK YOU BURGER THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
IT WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SAYING NO OPPOSITION
DUCTWORK -- SO I AM SUPPORTING
THE BILL.
AND YOU'LL BE SURE OF THAT.
EVEN THOUGH I LAST LOTS OF
QUESTIONS -- ONE IS THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING.
LOOKING AT SECTION NINE THIRTEEN
LIFE.
LET THE STAFF KNOW THAT I HAVE A
CONCERN HERE.
IT SAYS THAT YOU LOOK AT EACH
PROGRAM MANDATE MANDATED BY
STATUTE AND ITS ANNUAL COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS THAT'S PARAGRAPH.
ONE PARAGRAPH TO IS EACH PROGRAM
MANDATED BY THE COMMISSION ITS
ANNUAL COST TO TRACK TO
TAXPAYERS.
BUT THEN AND BELOW IT JUST SAYS
DESCRIBED IN PARAGRAPH ONE I
THINK YOU WANT PARAGRAPHS ONE
AND TWO IS THAT CORRECT OR NOT.
OKAY THAT'S PROBABLY CORRECT.
THE OTHER PART.
IS I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU DIVIDE
UP.
LET'S JUST TAKE THE LAST THE
FIRST BILL WE HEARD FRIEDMAN
SPELL.
OUT SAYING THE COMMUNITY SHOULD
HAVE A GRID.
AND THAT TAKES ES DE UP MONEY
AND SET IT UP FOR COMMUNITY.
NOW I COMMUNITY WHEN YOU FIRST
START OUT COULD HAVE NO
COMMERCIAL AND THEN A WEEK LATER
COMMERCIAL COMES IN AND THEN
MAYBE AN INDUSTRY COMES IN.
AND MAYBE THERE'S MORE FAR MEAN
IT'S HARD TO SAY HOW WHEN YOU
HELP A WHOLE COMMUNITY IT SHOULD
BE DIVIDED UP.
LET'S TAKE -- THE PROGRAM ON
BATTERY PROCUREMENT.
SOME OF THAT WILL BE IN HOMES
AND I GUESS THAT YOU COULD SAY
IS RESIDENTIAL SOME OF THAT'S
GOING TO BE DONE BY INDUSTRY.
BUT OTHERS JUST PEOPLE OUT THERE
SELLING -- BATTERIES ARE POWER
TO INDUSTRY OR HOMES OR WHATEVER
SO THAT THEY CAN DISPLACE THE
LOAD WHEN THEY HAVE TO PAY THE
HIGHER LOAD.
SO HOW YOU KNOW IT MAY BE
DIVIDED UP A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS.
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF PROGRAMS
THAT I THINK YOU'D HAVE A HARD
TIME DIVIDING UP INTO THESE FOUR
PARTS.
AND YOU MIGHT BE BETTER OFF JUST
SAYING WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT THE
COST OF PROGRAMS.
AND THEN AFTER THE FACT MAYBE
MAKE AN ANALYSIS OF HOW MUCH
WENT TO EACH BUT I'M JUST
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN
DO AN ACCURATE.
DIVISION I THINK YOU CAN GET A
NUMBER FOR EACH PROGRAM AND YOU
CAN HAVE AN IDEA.
BUT TO ASK FOR ACCURACY I I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN QUITE GET
THERE.
YET JUST IN RESPONSE TO THAT AS
PART OF OUR GENERATE CASES IN
FACE TO THE COMMISSION DECIDES
WHAT PORTION OF THE TOTAL
REVENUE REQUIREMENT GETS
ASSIGNED TO COMMERCIAL CLASS AG
CLASS RESIDENTIAL CLASS.
AND THOUGH THAT'S HOW WOULD BE
FIGURED OUT AMONGST THE
DIFFERENT RATE CLASSES AS PART
OF OUR HIZO FOR S. YET THEY'LL
MAKE SOME SORT OF AN ARBITRARY I
DON'T HOW WORK SPECIFIC CHANGE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT ESCAPE HAS
ITS OWN REVENUE REQUIREMENT
ATTACHED TO IT THE REVENUE
REQUIREMENT IS -- MOVED INTO THE
RATE STRUCTURE THROUGH --
REVENUE ALLOCATION PROCESS AND
IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE SIMPLE WHEN
YOU HAVE A STRAIGHT UP REVENUE
REQUIREMENT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE IMPACT IS ON A CENTS PER
KILOWATT HOUR BASIS OR CENTS PER
THERM BASIS FOR INDIVIDUAL
CUSTOMERS.
I THINK THE HARDER CASE THAT YOU
MIGHT BE POINTING AT OUR
PROGRAMS THAT DON'T HAVE AN
EXPLICIT REVENUE REQUIREMENT
ATTACHED TO THEM MOVING SO A
MANDATE WHERE PROCUREMENT
HAPPENS AND THE QUESTION BECOMES
WELL HOW MUCH DID THAT COST.
AND REALLY WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IS
WHAT IS THE ABOVE MARKET COST
WHAT'S THE COST EFFECTIVENESS OF
THAT.
AND I THINK MAYBE IF THE
COMMISSION CAN'T ANSWER SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS THAT RAISES SOME
INTERESTING AVENUES FOR FURTHER
WORK BY THE COMMISSION TO FIGURE
OUT.
HOW THEY ESTABLISH THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF SOME OF THESE
INITIATIVES ALRIGHT WELL PERHAPS
IF THERE COULD BE SOME LANGUAGE
TO JUST -- RECOGNIZED THAT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ASK THEM TO
DO THE IMPOSSIBLE BUT TO GET
THEIR BEST ESTIMATE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY AND WE'RE WORKING WITH AND
WHAT THE AUTHOR IS WORKING WITH
THE PC I'M ON THE DETAILS OF HOW
THAT INFORMATION WILL BE
COLLECTED.
SO THAT IT WON'T BE OPPOSED TO
ANYTHING THAT NOTHING THAT'S
IMPOSSIBLE OR LIKE THAT WILL BE
IMPOSED ON THEM [inaudible]
GARCIA -- AND I'LL BE WAITING
FOR THE BILL TODAY AND IT'S OR
TALKING ABOUT.
THINGS THAT ARE POSSIBLE AND
IMPOSSIBLE TO QUANTIFY OUT THERE
BUT I I DO HAVE CONCERNS AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT COST AND AND
BENEFITS -- WHEN WE DRAW SOME OF
THESE HARD LINES THAT WE DON'T
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE HEALTH
IMPROVEMENTS -- AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT AND SO FORTH THAT
SOMETIMES.
WE DON'T TAKE INTO THAT ANALYSIS
AND JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE AS WE
DOING.
THIS.
REPORT WHICH I THINK EFFECTIVE
RIGHT THING TO DO I APPRECIATED
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT SOMEBODY
SAID DIFFERENT TYPES OF HUMAN
COST AND IF IT'S ALONG THE WAY
AS WELL.
AND I WOULD GO THROUGH THE CHAIR
AND I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU I
THINK THAT THIS REPORT IN THE
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WERE
WORKING ON I'M SO THAT WE CAN
KIND OF GET TO AN ANALYSIS OF
WHY OUR RATES ARE WHERE THEY ARE
AND WHAT WE CAN.
WHAT WE CAN DO TO MITIGATE SOME
OF THE THE ISSUES WERE HAVING
WITH OUR RATES IT'S JUST FOR
INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES I DON'T
THINK THAT ANYONE OF US -- WOULD
NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT SOME OF
THE HEALTH BENEFITS AND SOME OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL BELL BENEFITS
THAT COME WITH A LOT OF PROGRAMS
WE PUT TOGETHER.
I THINK AT THIS POINT THOUGH IT
IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY WITH ALL
OF THE ADDITIONAL -- SITUATIONS
THAT ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
IMPOSE.
WAIT ON OUR RANGE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE LOOK AT THOSE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE DOING BOTH
WELL EVERYTHING THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING OUR
MANDATES.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND THE
MOTION IS -- DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR -- GRAIN TO THE
AMENDMENTS.
SO THERE ANOTHER QUESTION SO
WILL CALL THE ROLL ON THE MOTION.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE HI BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO ON MY CHIN.
GEN I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA AYE.
NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN SKEWS ME.
I RAY S. [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI QUIRK YES QUIRK I
REYES.
SANTIAGO TEEN.
YEAH MISSION I'M.
EXCUSE ME MAYES MAYES AYE.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT THERE HE
NINE VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR CAPTION HEARD CERTAINLY.
OFF.
BURGER HERE FOR YOUR BILL NOW.
ABSOLUTELY NO YEAH.
WELL AS YOU KNOW EVERYONE ELSE'S.
SO IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
IN THIS IS A DO A PASS -- TO
NATURALRESOURCES AND THE MENACE
TO BE TAKEN NATURAL RESOURCES I
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
A 100% I CAN ACTUALLY SAY THAT
FOR MYSELF WHICH IS AMAZING --
I'LL BE BRIEF I AM HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB FIFTY NO THREE WHICH
WOULD DIRECT THE CPU TO INCLUDE
ITS BIENNIAL SMART GREAT
DEPLOYMENT REPORT AN EVALUATION
OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STATE'S
DEPLOYMENT.
OF MICROCREDIT SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
UNLESS SOMEONE HAS A LOT TO SAY.
OSHO SECOND -- IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR THE BILL
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- WE HAVE A MOTION
IN FRONT.
BUT THERE'S NO MOTION.
YEAH YEAH I THOUGHT I WAS
THINKING YEAH.
NO COMMENTS NO COM.
THEY'RE SICK OF ME I OKAY SO
LET'S CALL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE OKAY THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PATIENCE TODAY ARE A VERY
GOOD JOB -- ROLL CALL PLEASE.
YES IT WAS THE DO PASS.
THE BEST AS AMENDED TO
CORPORATIONS NO NO I'M SORRY I'M
ENOUGH TO RESOURCES.
HOLDEN COMMITTED TO A PLACE AS
ANY TO GO.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE HI BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I IS THERE IN.
THEIR IN I MAYES.
I URGE TO G. QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
REYES.
SANTIAGO TING [inaudible]
YOU'RE WELCOME.
YOUR BILL IS OUT I WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OF WE WILL -- AS WE WAIT FOR
MISS RADIUS -- TO PRESENT FOR
HER I KNOW.
THINGS UP WITH THIS ALL RIGHT.
WELL.
ZERO TWO SO LET'S MOVE.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE ROLE.
AND WE'RE GOING -- TO WE HAVE --
ASSEMBLY BILL.
BECAUSE I COULD SET.
BOTH OF THOSE ARE CONCERNED --
SO WELL LET'S LET'S ADD ONTO A
CONSENT WE HAVE ENOUGH.
TO THAT'S IN THE SECOND SET
[inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
CHEN -- THIS IS CONCEPT COLOR
THIS -- IT WOULD BE A ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE TWENTY THREE WORKS AND
A. B..
A TEN SEVENTEEN CHEN I
CUNNINGHAM -- IS THERE IN.
NAZARIAN I REYES SANTIAGO TEAM.
TEN VOTES WILL KEEP OF THE ROLE
OPEN.
LET'S GO TO THE TOP OF FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. FIFTY SIX
AND ORDER GARCIA THE BILL IS ON
CALL.
THEIR SIZE SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR.
IS THERE IN.
AYE NAZARIAN AYE.
REYES SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEEN.
OKAY THE BILL IS OUT WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN. FOR OF SOME
MEMBERS.
WELL AT A
FIVE FIVE FIVE TO TAKE
ON A FILE ITEM -- SEVEN SEWER
BURKE'S FIFTEEN OH THREE OF IN
TERMS OF THE MOTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED IT WAS HEARD ON THE MIKE
SO IT IS A DO PASSED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES.
WITH THE MEMBERS TO BE TAKEN AND
NATURAL RESOURCE.
YOU JUST NEED A YES FOR ME.
WE NEED A NEW MOTION.
GIVE ME JUST A SECOND
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT WE'RE
GONNA WE STILL HAVE SOME WORK TO
FINISH OUT ON NO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THAT.
THE NEXT ACTUALLY TAKE IS
CORRECT SO WE JUST.
LET THEM FIGURE THAT OUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE WILL TURN TO YOU --
AND WE WILL.
THE BILL IS AB NINE SIXTY WERE --
ONE THIS ENJOYS A DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL BE TAKEN UP IN
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
YES OKAY.
MANY OF THEM.
THERE YOU GO PLEASE PERCENT.
AND I DO WANT [inaudible]
TO GEN
[inaudible]
REPORTER.
GOV AB.
NINE SIXTY ONE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO ESTABLISH COMMON
DEFINITIONS FOR COMMUNITY NON
ENERGY BENEFITS THESE BENEFITS
WOULD INCORPORATE A
CONSIDERATION OF SOCIETAL.
AND SOCIAL COSTS WHEN LOOKING TO
DEPLOY CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS BILL STEMS FROM A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE SB THREE
FIFTY BARRIER STUDY.
RELEASED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WHICH HAD A RECOMMENDATION TO
ESTABLISH COMMON DEFINITIONS OF
NON ENERGY BENEFITS DEVELOP
STANDARDS TO MEASURE THEM AND
ATTEMPT TO DETERMINE CONSISTENT
VALUES.
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY OF OUR
LOW INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIESFACE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO ACCESS AFFORDABLE
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS. FOR
EXAMPLE FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE AVERAGE
ENERGY COST BURDEN FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WAS MORE
THAN THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
HIGHER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
IN ADDITION DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SUFFER BOTH ECONOMIC
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY ARE LOCATED IN AREAS WITH
CONCENTRATED SOURCES OF AIR
POLLUTION.
CURRENT COST EFFECTIVENESS TEST
DO NOT CONSISTENTLY CONSIDER
THESE AND OTHER NON ENERGY
BENEFITS AND THIS BILL DIRECTS
THE BROADER APPLICATION. TO
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THOSE DEPLOYING
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
BY MEANINGFULLY CONSIDERING AND
PRIORITIZING NON ENERGY BENEFITS
THIS BILL CREATES A FOUNDATION
TO IMPLEMENT THE MOST HOLISTIC
INEFFECTIVE CLEAN ENERGY
PROGRAMS POSSIBLE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THIS
ISSUE TAKES A CRITICAL FIRST
STEP.
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL.
ARE AT LUCY HERNANDEZ AND
ABIGAIL SO LEASE FROM SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES AND MADELINE STAY NO
STANO ON BEHALF OF THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MY NAME
IS LESLIE HERNANDEZ AND I'M FROM
WEST GOSHEN IT'S AN TULARE
COUNTY I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT A BEAD.
NINE SIXTY ONE IN MY COMMUNITY
WE HAVE TO USE PROPANE AND
BURNED WOOD TO HEAT OUR HOMES.
PROPANE IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
AND OUR RESIDENTS THERE AND OUR
COMMUNITY ARE VERY LOW INCOME
AND CAN AFFORD TO PAY FOR
PROPANE.
AB PROPANE -- WE HAD TO PAY UP
FRONT AND THERE IS NO PAYMENT
PLANS.
WE AVOID USING OR HEATERS AND
OTHER APPLIANCES BECAUSE WE CAN
AFFORD IT.
IT LEADS TO OUR CHILDREN GETTING
SICK.
FROM BEING CALLED AN MASON
SCHOOL ALSO PROPANE TANKS ARE
DANGEROUS.
SOME PEOPLE RUN THEIR OFFENSE
ALL NIGHT TO KEEP THEIR HOMES
WARM.
THIS IS A SAFETY ISSUE.
THIS RIO ISSUES SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED.
WHEN DETERMINING WHICH AT?
COMMUNITIES QUALIFY FOR CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAMS.
OUR COMMUNITY DESERVES A CLEAN
AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY SOURCE
SOURCE.
AB I AM A RATE PAYER.
TO IN MY COMMUNITY IS NOT
BENEFIT IN EQUALITY.
EQUALLY FROM I CALIFORNIA CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAMS.
AND THAT'S NOT FAIR.
I BELIEVE ALLOWING CONSIDER
CONSIDERATION.
FROM ISSUES THAT AFFECT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE ISSUES THAT MATTER.
THE MOST TO OUR COMMUNITY.
WILL HELP TO PRODUCE BETTER AND
MORE IF EFFECTIVE CLEAN ENERGY
PROJECTS.
AND I ASKED YOU GUYS FOR SUPPORT
AND AB NINETY SIX THE WENT
BECAUSE THIS WILL BENEFIT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON IF I COULD JUST
ADD I'M I'M ABIGAIL SLEEP
WITHOUT HELP ENTERPRISES WE ARE
A NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND WE WORK
DIRECTLY WITH DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES I'M HELPING THEM
ACCESS INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS.
ARE BETTER USUALLY MUCH NEEDED
I'M AND I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT ADD THIS BILL FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS THE ONE AB
NINE SIXTY ONE WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT WE VALUE THE
INTEREST OF OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
IT ALSO HELPS THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION COUNTY
ISSUES THAT MATTER MOST TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS IT IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSIONS ADOPTED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND SOCIAL
ACTION PLAN.
AND IT SUPPORTS ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES WITH AN EXISTING
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS.
AB NINE SIXTY ONE HELPS ENSURE
THAT WE VALUE THE INTERESTS OF
OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THESE COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT VERY VALUABLE AND
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
VALUES -- ARE -- ARE REPRESENTED --
YOU KNOW WHAT I'VE HEARD MENTION
HERE TODAY MANY TIMES THAT
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADING
INNOVATION -- HOWEVER.
THE BENEFITS OF THAT INNOVATION
IS NOT TRICKLING DOWN TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST THESE COMMUNITIES ARE AMONG
THE POOREST IN THE STATE HOWEVER
THEY SPENT A LOT THEY SPEND A
LARGER PORTION OF THEIR INCOME
ON THEIR UTILITY COST.
THEY LIVE IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE THE HIGHEST -- AIR
POLLUTION AND THE WORST AIR
QUALITY I SO -- I THINK IT'S
ONLY FAIR AND ABOUT TIME -- THAT
WE MAKE -- THE NECESSARY
IMPROVEMENTS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PROGRAMS ARE ASSISTING THOSE
THAT NEED IT THE MOST THE
POOREST COMMUNITIES WITH THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF AIR POLLUTION
AND THIS LEGISLATION IS THE
NECESSARY FIRST STEP. TO
CORRECTING THIS INEQUITY I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU X. WAS -- THANK YOU
AYE MATALIN SANTA WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE AND WE ARE
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
NONPROFIT LOCATED IN DOWNTOWN
OAKLAND.
AND I'M HERE TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY.
AT THAT IS THERE ANYONE FROM THE
AUDIENCE WHO WOULD LIKE.
TO LEND THEIR SUPPORT TO THIS
BILL [inaudible]
NAME [inaudible]
FILIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE CHAN AND I'M HERE
TO OFFER SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
FOR ORGANIZATIONS THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
THE RISING SUN CENTER FOR
OPPORTUNITY AND THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONEST FLORIO
FROM THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
COUNCIL AND WE WORK AND LOW IN
COMMUNITIES AND DO DIRECT
INSTALL FOR LOW INCOME PROGRAMS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THERE
ANYMORE REPRESENTING THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE MINOR REPRESENTING MCP
MARIN CLEAN ENERGY ALSO HAPPY TO
SUPPORT.
HELLO ALLEY TEACHER WITH NGO
WORK GLOBAL CLEAN ENERGY
DEVELOPER IN CALIFORNIA WE DO
LOT OF PROJECTS WITH SCHOOLS
CITIES COUNTIES AND WATER
AGENCIES TO WE INTEGRATE STEM
EDUCATION WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INTO THESE PROJECTS WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY ONE REALIZE ALL THESE
BENEFITS THESE PROGRAMS BRING.
DISCO SCHOOLS.
MY NAME'S ADRIAN UNDER WHAT NAME
HERE -- REPRESENTING SON RUN
VOTE SOLAR AND THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORED CESSATION AND
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M FROM A
LITTLE COMMUNITY OF SEVILLE ONE
OF THE POOREST COMMUNITIES IN
TAYLOR COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. FOR THE THIRD
NOTICING ON THEM OF ANYA.
THEN GOOD LUCK ON THE US A BILL.
THE LOCAL NOT TO LET IT YOUR
VOICE TO BE GOOD OFFICE.
STAN GRESCHNER GOOD ALTERNATIVES
OR NONPROFIT SOLAR ENERGY
STORAGE PROVIDER AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
BRENT AND ALSO SIERRA CLUB
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ACRE FERNANDEZ A LIVING TULARE
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THEIR WITNESSES OR
ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
OF THE S. OVER THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CAL CHAMBERS PARTICULAR CONCERN
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF AB NINE
SIXTY ONE ON ENERGY RATES IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AM SUCH A LOW TALKER I WILL BE
LEAN AND MORE SORRY ABOUT THAT.
AS YOU KNOW INDUSTRIAL
COMMERCIAL REPAIRS IN CALIFORNIA
PAY SOME OF THE HIRES HIGHEST
ENERGY RATES IN THE UNITED
STATES AND ARE IN CONSTANT
COMPETITION WITH OTHER STATES
RETENTION ON MANUFACTURING
AGRICULTURE AND OTHER ENERGY
INTENSIVE PRODUCTS.
THE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS EXPECT
AND DEMAND WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AND THE
CONSIDERATION OF CO BENEFITS OF
ENERGY PROGRAMS ADDITION MAGIC
COMMUNITIES IS AN ONGOING
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION.
HOWEVER HERE THE STEEP UC'S
EXPERT HE SAYS IN ECONOMICS WHEN
QUANTIFIABLE COSTS A
QUANTIFIABLE BENEFITS TO
DETERMINE THE REASONABLE RATES
CHARGED CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES.
CPUC IS ALREADY RAMPING UP ITS
EXPERTISE IN SAFETY TO RESPOND
TO THE EVER INCREASING THREAT OF
WILDFIRES IN CLIMATE RELATED
ISSUES WHICH FOCUSES RIGHTLY A
PRIORITY OF THE STATE.
WITH WILDFIRES INCREASING ENERGY
COSTS AND OTHER CRISES FACING
CPUC THIS YEAR ADDING ON THE
BURDEN OF DEVELOPING IN ANOTHER
AREA OF EXPERTISE IS A CHALLENGE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO INCORPORATE
PRIORITIZE A NEW DEFINITION IN
THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
PERFORMED BY THE CPUC.
AND USES QUITE A BROAD CATEGORY
TO GUIDE THE DEFINITION ON ENTRY
TO BENEFITS WELL WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESSTO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS LIVING THE
SCOPE OF NON ENERGY BENEFITS TO
CERTAIN PROGRAMS.
WE BELIEVE THE DISCUSSION TO
CONTINUE AS A C. P. YOU SEE A
STUDY THIS ISSUE IN THE PAST AND
IT'S INDICATED THAT THESE
BENEFITS ARE HARD TO QUANTIFY.
AND ARE PARTICULARLY UNRELIABLE
BECAUSE THEY LARGELY RELY ON
SELF REPORTING CUSTOMER SURVEYS
RATHER THAN THE EMPIRICAL DATA
IT STUDIES THE TYPICALLY GUIDE A
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS.
FINALLY WE BELIEVE THAT SHIFTING
OF SOCIETAL COSTS AND BENEFITS
SOLELY ON TO WRITE PAPERS.
RATE THE RATE PAYERS IS NOT
APPROPRIATE DELEGATION OF
AUTHORITY TO THIS RATE MAKING
AGENCY. FOR THESE REASONS CAL
CHEAPER RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES AB
NINE SIXTY ONE AND LOOKS FOR TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH YOUR
OFFICE.
TO ADDRESS THESE REMAINING
CONCERTS.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OKAY.
I CHAIR MEMBERS OR DOES HE
MENACE WITH SEMPRA ENERGY ALSO
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AT THE
MOMENT -- WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
WILL REVIEW THOSE FURTHER TO SEE
WHERE WE MIGHT STAND -- MOVING
FORWARD BUT NOW WE APPRECIATE
THE OBJECTIVES OF THE BILL --
BUT AS AT THE ORIGINAL AS
WRITTEN WE THOUGHT IT WAS
DEPICTED IN MAY BE COSTLY SO
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW THIS
ALL WORKS BECAUSE MOST OF OUR
PROCUREMENT.
IT'S GOING TO BE DONE BY THE
CCA'S THE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS.
AND ON THE P. YOU SEE IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO TELL THEM
WHAT TO DO.
SO I'M NOT SURE THAT -- I'M NOT
CCA
SOLAR IN A PARTICULAR AREA --
BUT SAYS CLEAN ENERGY AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY I COULD SEE.
OR IT WANTS TO DO AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM CAN THE CPUC
EVEN TELL THE CCA WHAT TO DO --
SO THE INTENT OF THE BILL AND AS
AS IT'S WRITTEN -- WE DON'T
BELIEVE TOUCHES PROCUREMENT AT
THAT LEVEL -- SO REALLY THE BILL
ALLOWS THE CPUC TO CONSIDER
THESE NON ENERGY BENEFITS WHEN
MAKING DECISIONS ON D. E. R. SO
DOESN'T PRESCRIBE ANYTHING
DOESN'T FORCE THEM TO DIRECT --
RESOURCES IN A PARTICULAR AREA.
AND IT ALSO DOESN'T CHANGE
EXISTING COST EFFECTIVENESS
TESTS IT'S A SUPPLEMENTAL LAYER
OF ANALYSIS WHICH PERMITS THE
CPUC TO CONSIDER CO BENEFITS
LIKE HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABILITY -- SO
TO YOUR QUESTION I I DON'T SHARE
THAT -- AS A CONCERN -- AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE C.
P. YOU SEE TO MAKE SURE THE
SCOPE IS LIMITED AND EASY.
TO IMPLEMENT SO WHAT PROGRAMS
WOULD BE AFFECTED SO THE LATE
NIGHT ENERGY PROCUREMENT IF THE
LISTED PROGRAMS UNDER D. E. R. --
IT'S A SERIES OF PROGRAM SO I
DON'T WANT TO MISS QUOTE THE
ACTUAL NUMBER -- BUT WE GAVE A
CITATION TO THE PUBLIC.
UTILITIES CODE SECTION THAT
LISTS OUT THOSE PROGRAMS --
CESAR LIST IN THE ANALYSIS
PERHAPS THERE IS A PARTIAL LIST
IN THE ANALYSIS -- SO IT'S AN
IDEAL EXAMPLE RIGHT -- AND I
COME TO THIS AND WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE AS REGULATORY
PRACTITIONER AT THE CPUC --
WOULD BE IN THE CONTEXT OF A
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAM -- SO --
LUCY AND ABIGAIL HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PROCEEDING WHERE WE'RE
PILOTING NEW CLEAN ENERGY
PROJECTS.
IN THE COURSE OF THAT PROCEEDING
WE HAD TO ARGUE VERY HARD FOR
THINGS LIKE HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THE P. UC'S
DECISION MAKING PROCESS TO
AUTHORIZE THOSE PILOTS.
THIS BILL GIVES OPENS THE DOOR
FOR THE P. YOU SEE TO CONSIDER.
THOSE OTHER CO BENEFITS WHEN
THEY MAKE THEIR DECISION AGAIN
IT'S NOT PRESCRIPTIVE -- AND
ALSO IN RESPONSE TO OTHER
QUESTIONS IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
QUANTITATIVE SO WE WORK WITH THE
P. YOU SEE TO MAKE SURE THEIR
CONCERN WAS THAT.
THIS DEFINITION WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER PROGRAMS --
SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND AND
THAT THE LANGUAGE REFLECTS THAT
THIS CAN BE QUANTITATIVE OR
QUALITATIVE OKAY SO IT'S PRIMARY.
SO I GOT WORD FROM THE CHAIR.
THAT ITS PRIMARY ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROGRAMS IS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY CRACK SO THIS WOULD
MEAN ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
WOULD GO PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF
THE IT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY GO
TO FOR EXAMPLE A POOR RURAL
COMMUNITY BECAUSE SINCE YOU'VE
CHANGED IT TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SCREEN.
IF THEY HAVE GOOD AIR THEY DON'T
QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAM.
THAT'S NOT HOW WE INTERPRET THE
BILL SO THE BILL REQUIRES
TRACKING -- AND MEASURING OF NON
ENERGY BENEFITS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE PRIORITIZATION OF PROJECTS
THAT PROMOTE THOSE BENEFITS IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES WHICH WAS THE
LANGUAGE WE ORIGINALLY USED --
WHICH GOES BEYOND THE CAL ENVIRO
SCREEN WE'VE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENT BUT IT WENT BROADER
JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE -- WELL I AS I READ THE
MEN MINUTES SAYS CALLIN VIRUS
SCREEN YES YES AND THEN SO HOW
DOES HE GO BROADER HOW IT FATED
SERIOUSLY IN.
IT.
I EVEN DID YOU DEVIOUSLY A DEAD
BUT NOW THAT IT'S CALLUM VIRUS
SCREEN WHAT HOW TO PEOPLE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES ACCESS IT --
THAT THEY WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO
ACCESS ALL OF THESE BENEFITS AND
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY STILL BE
ALLOWED TO MAKE THE NON ENERGY
BENEFIT ARGUMENTS FOR INVESTMENT
IN THEIR COMMUNITY IN A WAY THAT
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO RIGHT NOW.
SO THIS DOESN'T DIRECT OR
MANDATE PROJECTS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND ALLOWS THE CPUC
TO CONSIDER THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE UNDERSERVED AND
OVER POLLUTED WHEN THEY MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENT AND
PROGRAMMATIC EVALUATION DECISION
YOU BUT IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
A RURAL COMMUNITY -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY IS ALWAYS SAYING OR
WOOD IS SAYING WE DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE COVERED IN
THIS.
BY THE HEALTH BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SCREEN BUT WE HAVE
PLENTY OF POVERTY.
A SO I FIRST UP THERE ARE --
INCOME PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
THAT MIGHT INCLUDE THOSE
COMMUNITIES FOR PRIORITIZATION
WERE CROSSED OUT -- I THINK
MOVING FORWARD I MEAN AND THAT
THAT IS A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR I KNOW THE STAKEHOLDERS
ARE COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THAT THIS.
BILL A IS AS BENEFICIAL AS
POSSIBLE INCLUDING RURAL
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE MEMBERS OF
REAL COMMUNITIES HERE I HAVE
BEEN WORKING.
ON THAT ISSUE SO RESPECTFULLY I
THINK WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO THINK THROUGH HOW
TO DO THAT AND WE ACCEPT THAT --
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WENT WITH
A DIFFERENT DIRECTION AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU IF I COULD JUST ADD TO
THAT -- I APPRECIATE THAT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE THEIR OWN UNIQUE SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THAT SOME MAY
NOT NECESSARILY BENEFIT FROM THE
COUNT BY RISK FREE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THESE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS.
BUT I JUST REALLY WANT TO STRESS
THAT IN CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
VALLEY WE HAVE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
BOTH THEY ARE VERY LOW INCOME
THEY ARE.
AGRICULTURE WORKERS FARM
LABORERS AND ON TOP OF THAT THEY
HAVE THE WORST AIR QUALITY AND
THE MOST AIR POLLUTION IN THE
STATE BECAUSE THEY'RE CENTERED
AROUND LARGE AG LANDS AND
FARMING PRACTICES THAT DIRECTLY
AFFECT THEIR AIR THEIR WATER.
SO THESE I WOULDN'T I WOULD
STATE THAT THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
EVEN MORE IMPACTED AND THOSE WHO
DO NOT BENEFIT FROM THE CAL ON
BY ROSE SCREEN AT THIS TIME YEAH
I AGREE WITH YOU BUT YOU DID
HAVE PEOPLE FROM.
COMMUNITY SPEAKING HERE WHO
WOULD NOT BE BENEFIT IT DOWN AND
I THINK [inaudible]
WELL.
WILL AGREE TO DISAGREE.
BEFORE THE BEFORE THE CHAIR CUTS
ME OFF JUST ACT THE COMMUNITY IF
THE BILL IS HERE AND THE
COMMITTEE OF WEST GOSHEN THEY
ARE -- SIGNIFICANT THEY ON THE
CALAVERAS GREEN DAY SCORE HI
THAT'S THE HIGHEST.
AND I THINK THE INTENTION OF THE
AUTHOR WAS TO TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS A RECOGNITION THAT --
COMMUNITIES ARE DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS WERE GOING TO BE
HAVE SOME FORM OF OF FOCUSED
ATTENTION THAT'S WHAT WE WERE
TRYING TO TO GET.
TO WITH THE RECOMMENDATION SO.
I THINK WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE HERE.
I ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
IS OUR MOTION -- THE MOTION OF
YOUR IN THIS RACE YOU DO HAVE A
ENJOYED DO PASSES A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN
YES.
OKAY I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
OF A TAKING.
SHE HAS HAPPENED AT ALL.
THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
OKAY SO YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
GET TOGETHER I THINK I'M I CAN'T
WAIT TILL THURSDAY SO EARLY I'M --
PURSUED BY FOR SOME ACCELERATOR.
MOVED THEY'LL.
THANK YOU SIR HAS BEEN MOVED --
THROUGH PASS MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
MEMBERS OF THE EXECUTIVE HOLDEN
BY ALL THE HIGH PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO BURKE.
I CAMILLE.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN NO CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I NAZARIAN.
HI NAZARIAN AYE.
NECESSARY OF MAYES.
MURATSUCHI WHERE'S THE GI QUIRK
AYE QUIRK HI REYES I YES I SENT
SAN DIEGO SANTIAGO.
I TING.
AS TEN VOTES YOU'RE A OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
OF LET'S BE BEFORE -- MEMBERS
EVEN IF YOU'VE -- EVEN IF YOU'VE
ACTUALLY VOTED ON THESE MEASURES.
YEAH LET ME JUST MAKE SURE GIVE
ME JUST A SECOND BEFORE YOU
LEAVE.
THE CALL DOT.
NOW.
I KNOW.
YOU'RE SENDING ME.
TO WRITE OKAY HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO -- WE'RE GOING.
TO OPEN THE ROLE ON A. B.
FIFTEEN OH THREE BURKE -- WHEN
THE MOTION WAS INITIALLY -- READ
INTO THE RECORD -- IT.
REFLECTED THAT THE BILL WAS
GOING TO BE AMENDED AND
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS OPPOSED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND SO THE MOTION.
GOING TO HAVE TO READ THE MISSUS.
JUST TO CLEAN UP. TWO THOUSAND
ACRES ISRAEL PAYROLL AND OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE AGAIN
ON BURKE FIFTEEN OH THREE THE
MOTION WOULD BE DO PASS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES WITHIN MINUTES
TAKEN AND NATURAL RESOURCES
[inaudible]
SECOND.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
HOLDEN.
HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
NOW BOATING.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE AYE.
CARILLO.
I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I NAZARIAN.
MAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE MAYES.
MERCI G. MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK.
WORK I REYES.
AS I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TING.
TING HI.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK THROUGH
THE ROLE AND THEN MOVE THAT
MOTIONS WELL AS TWELVE TWELVE IN
FAVOR.
MOTION CARRIES [inaudible]
EUROPE [inaudible]
I'M.
OKAY OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THAT MISTER PATTERSON.
IS A AS I SO HE'S GOING TO
CHANGES VOTE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON VOTING TO AN ASIDE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO.
LOOKING FOR YEAH.
OKAY THIRTEEN VOTES IN FAVOR.
OKAY FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
LET'S GO BACK.
TO AND TAKE ADD ON'S.
A STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR CALLING ABSENT
MEMBERS -- CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO [inaudible]
CONSENT.
SANTIAGO I TEAM.
TING HI [inaudible]
THIRTEEN
YEAH.
IF THAT HAS FOURTEEN VOTES
[inaudible]
SO WE'LL.
GO THROUGH OF THIS ONE TIME AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK AROUND --
START THE TOP OF THE FILE.
AB -- FIFTY SIX REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I TEAM.
TING HI.
YEAH SO WE AND FROM AND FIFTEEN
CAREER ELEVEN IN FAVOR TO OPPOSE --
HI AB [inaudible]
NINE SIXTY ONE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
ACCORDING. TEN IN FAVOR AND TO
OPPOSE.
AB.
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR CARILLO
[inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
YES SIR.
THANK YOU CHEN [inaudible]
CHEN I IS THERE IN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN I REYES.
REYES I TING.
TING I HAS TWELVE VOTES IN FAVOR.
AB [inaudible]
TWELVE NINETY THREE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
REYES.
FANSITES SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO ON EIGHTEEN YES NOT
TOTAL.
ALL OF THEM [inaudible]
THE OTHER [inaudible] FORTY FOUR
WE HAD ON YEAH OFTENTIMES
.
OKAY.
OKAY THE PROPOSED CONSENT YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WHERE WERE JUST GREAT
LET'S KEEP GOING OKAY?
YEAH.
NUMBER.
SEVEN AB [inaudible]
FIFTEEN OH THREE CUNNINGHAM.
AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN NINETY NINE CARILLO
[inaudible]
CHEN.
CHEN NO CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
NAZARIAN I REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO ON EIGHTEEN TING I NINE
A CERTAIN IN FAVOR.
AND WHO KNOWS -- WE'RE MR --
MURATSUCHI YOU HAVE SOME BILLS
WHICH IS STILL INTO OUT ONTO.
I DIDN'T HEAR MY NAME.
NUMBER SIX BUT I NUMBER.
SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER.
BAKER [inaudible]
YES.
BUT NO I DO NOT.
AB TWELVE NINETY THREE MAYOR
SAID SHE SAID SHE AYE
[inaudible]
MORE RAIN [inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible]
GOOD.
OKAY WE ARE MADE OUR WAY THROUGH
THE AGENDA AND WE HAVE OVER
VOTES RECORDED THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED